hello everyone welcome to the November
2023 ask me anything edition of the
mindescape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carol not a lot of things to share with
you before we get into it today but I
did think that this might be an
effective place to stop and reflect a
bit on teaching which I'm doing again
now you know when I was at Caltech which
I was when I started mindscape 5 years
ago I basically didn't do any teaching I
taught one course the entire time I was
at Caltech for whatever it was 16 years
and of course I done plenty of teaching
before that at the University of Chicago
and even a little bit at MIT and Harvard
but um it's been a while I'm Rusty right
I'm out of practice and more importantly
the kind of teaching I have been doing
so far at John's Hopkins has been
different than what I am familiar with
from my previous experience which was
mostly lecturing Advanced physics topics
um at the University of Chicago for
example when you're a theoretical phys
phys assist you are almost always
assigned graduate level courses to teach
they have that informal distinction
there I did teach a couple of
undergraduate courses I taught a uh I
started a course on undergraduate
general relativity which is very popular
and uh shotti B who was a former
mindscape guest she and I co-taught A
Course in a humani course on moments in
atheism on the intellectual history of
atheism throughout the ages and that was
kind of a classic thing where it was
supposed to be a seminar but then a lot
of people wanted to take it and we ended
up letting a lot of people take it and
then it just turns into lectures you
can't have 40 people in the room and
give everyone really a full chance to
speak so I haven't had this experience
before that I've had both this year and
last year at Hopkins of really just
sitting in the room with 12 people and
have it truly be a discussion-based
seminar which I always love those are
always my favorite courses when When I
Was An undergraduate I do have very
strong opinions that a good
old-fashioned lecture is still an
awesome Paradigm for teaching I remember
once when I was uh not long after I had
been at MIT and I taught a big lecture
course there in general relativity which
later turned into the textbook that I
wrote SpaceTime and geometry and I was
mentioning this to someone who was an
expert in education you know who had
actually uh T had a degree in education
and they said well what kind of course
was it and I said well you know it was a
graduate course in general relativity
basically I stood up and I taught them
general relativity just by a lectures
and the response was well that's not
really teaching at all that doesn't
count as teaching to them if you're not
interacting if you're not having
discussions Etc then it's not really
teaching at all and I thought that was
kind of a silly attitude to take uh as I
am with many things I'm kind of a
pluralist about teaching methods if you
want to teach
general relativity I think that probably
the best thing is to give them the
content via some method whether it's
lecturing or anything else now I know
that not everyone agrees you know Andy
Stringer who was a former mindscape
guest uh famously would have student he
would teach graduate general relativity
and he would have students do problems
in real time in the class that does save
you some lecturing uh preparation time
if you're the professor but I think that
there's just so much stuff you got to
get across that I have no objections
whatsoever to standing up in and
lecturing in front of the class but I I
do treasure also the sitting around a
table and having everyone have their say
and having a true discussion which I've
been doing this year especially last
year again I had one of those things
where there was supposed to be a seminar
and I let too many people in and it
turned into a lecture um and I think
that honestly I'm still not very good at
it at leading the seminar discussions
I'm getting better I try very hard
there's a fine line right you have to
give them some content you have to guide
you are the boss right you are the one
who's supposed to know what's going on
and the first year students these are
all undergraduates the first year
students especially um it's all new to
them right I mean High School is
lectures or if you even want to call it
that but High School is not sitting
around a table with 12 people and deeply
discussing an individual text so they
are not used to that which is fine
that's something point in our lives none
of us are used to these things whereas
the upper level the seniors and juniors
are you know they've done this before
they're old hats they're good at talking
etc etc but I think that that that
perfect line between giving new content
and letting them talk is a is a very
tricky one and then not to mention you
know what do you talk about you know do
you let them do you let the students
wander off into what they think is
interesting which I kind of like to do
right if they think it's interesting
that's a win that for you as the Prof
professor as far as I'm concerned but
again there's certain notes you have to
hit there's certain beats you have to
reach in the in the course of your
course as it were it's not unlike doing
a podcast interview where you know
there's certain things that you want to
talk about that's why you invited
someone to be on the podcast but
sometimes they want to wander off and
maybe you hit something really
interesting by letting them do that I
have no point to talking about this but
you know it's the AMA I get to ramble on
a little bit at the beginning cuz you're
going to sit and listen to me for hours
now after this occasional reminder of
course this is the AMA if you want to
know where these questions come from
they come from people who support
mindscape on patreon those people could
be you if you wanted to support
mindscape just go to
patreon.com shanm Carol M as in Michael
my middle name and uh sign up to send a
dollar to to mindscape per episode it's
not that much money much less than you
probably spend on coffee or tea or soda
every every uh week and you get
mindscape of course you already get
mindscape for free it will always there
will always be free mindscape I don't I
hope that I never I can't imagine ever
putting like making the podcast and put
it putting it behind a pay wall that
would be weird but you do get it ad free
and also more importantly you get to be
part of that patreon community that asks
the AMA questions you get little
reflection videos that I do after each
episode uh and you get a sense of
accomplishment for helping you support
the podcast helping me helping me stay
motivated to do the podcast for among
other things uh and the other thing I
wanted to remind you of of course is the
mindscape big picture scholarship I I
keep forgetting to mention this but not
only is this something that you can
donate to but you can also apply to if
you're a high school student and you
want to go to college and study big
picture kinds of ideas so this is
sponsored by bold.org
b.org so go to bold. .org and search for
mindscape or go to bold.org
scholarships mindscape the idea here is
that we are getting donations from you
nice mindscape listeners you've been
extraordinarily generous uh we did this
last year and we gave two scholarships
away we're doing it again and we're on
track to give at least one hopefully
though I would like to give another two
this year and we're not there yet so um
we need a few more people to um kick in
and then we'll be able to do it and uh I
think it's a great
it's a great service right I mean it's
enough money it's $10,000 to the winners
that's enough money to really help them
get through college maybe influence some
people who wouldn't have been able to do
it otherwise the application deadline if
you are uh a young person thinking of
applying is December 15 so go to
bold.org don't just apply to mindscape
you know apply to all these other
scholarships there's plenty of
opportunities there there's one thing
you know it's free to apply so plenty of
people apply who are clearly not
actually fitting the criteria I get it
why not why not apply but I'm especially
interested in people who want to for
their future career study the deepest
Mysteries of the universe whether it's
in physics or philosophy or anything
else biology or mathematics or whatever
it's the bigness it's the abstractness
it's the fundamentality that we're
looking for here so hopefully we can
find some appropriate students to give
money to this year looking forward to
that and I think that's it in another
words let's
[Music]
go Roland Weber says will the biggest
ideas in the universe part two be
comprehensible by itself or do you
expect readers to have worked through
part one already an excellent question
roll and uh one that I struggled with
and the rough answer like if I have to
give a one-word answer is no I do not
expect it to be comprehensible by itself
of course the reason why there needs to
be a longer answer is because people are
different different people have
different levels of preparation um It's
Perfectly comprehensible to someone who
knows the basics of calculus and
classical mechanics now one way of
getting those Basics is through the
biggest ideas volume one SpaceTime and
motion
if you already have them from some other
purpose uh from other some other part of
your life where you learned a little bit
of calculus a little bit of ntoni
mechanics maybe you know what a vector
is that would be helpful um then you can
read the biggest ideas part two no
problem but I I thought about you know
can I make it self-contained but you
know in part one there's whole long
discussions of what is a derivative and
what is an integral for example um
there's shorter but important
discussions on what is a hamiltonian
what is a vector and and I can't just
reput those in volume two I'm afraid so
it's pretty basic stuff I didn't want to
make the prerequisites as it were too
much so that the right kind of people
can still very very happily pick up
volume two and be fine um but certainly
you know if if the ambition is to take
the smart but completely doesn't know
anything about physics or math person
and bring them from that level to pretty
uh Broad knowledge of the main ideas of
modern physics which is my goal then you
should read volume one as well as volume
two keep in mind um my original idea was
a was a gigantic book what single volume
right that was my idea the publishing
industry did not like my idea the
Apparently big books don't sell that
much and these days uh for whatever
reason I don't know I blame Tik Tok um
but they wanted to split it into
multiple books so we they wanted more
than three we compromised on three but
it is of a piece it is a continuous kind
of narrative it does build on itself
that's one of the things about physics
it is it is cumulative so um feel free
to buy them volume two and maybe then
they will be inspired to go out and buy
volume one or vice versa the other the
final thing to say about that is of
course all of these books were inspired
were are based on videos that I did
right that you can still find on YouTube
so feel free to just give the um biggest
ideas volume two which is called Quant
and Fields and um let them catch up by
watching the videos right that's always
fine and by the way so you know I guess
there probably are some people listening
to this who don't know what we're
talking about here I wrote um this book
the biggest ideas in the universe volume
one SpaceTime in motion it's been out
did very well uh was very gratified at
the response and it was about classical
mechanics and relativity volume two will
be about quantum mechanics and Quantum
field Theory and I I think that people
despite the fact that I say it all the
time people don't quite believe me it's
mostly Quantum field Theory it is not
mostly quantum mechanics so it's not a
book about you know many worlds or
foundations of quantum mechanics or
anything like that it's a book about
effective field Theory and gauge
theories and findan diagrams and
renormalization and symmetry breaking
and confinement and the spin statistics
theorem and all of the stuff
that goes into our modern understanding
of quantum field Theory and particle
physics as such it does get you know um
pretty far removed from one's everyday
experience sometimes you know effective
I think effective field theories are
kind of the centerpiece of the book The
Lynch pin the thing that I think that is
the biggest difference between how much
people do know about it and how much
people should know about it um more
people should know about effective field
theories and this book is going to help
teach you
and it's also the book where you know of
the three there'll be a third volume
where we talk about complexity and
emergence um you know volume one was
different than most popular physics
books because of all the equations and
so forth but it does have close
relatives um the the two classic
examples two most obvious examples are
Roger penrose's book The Road to Reality
and Lenny susins series of books um the
theoretical minimum both of which former
mindscape guests but that's okay their
books came first so I'm not competing
with their royalties but uh volume two
even though it overlaps with some of the
stuff that is in their books mostly
doesn't the stuff that is in volume two
the stuff is in Quantum and Fields is
mostly stuff you're just not going to
get anywhere else I mean I hope it's
good that's not to say that I do it well
I hope that I ended up doing it well
enough but it is something that is
pretty unique in terms of um a book
aimed at a wide audience so we'll see
how it
goes Dave grunder says what would you do
differently if you became 100%
independently wealthy and had the
unconstrained ability to fund your own
research including hiring researchers
and buying equipment would you create
your own research institute retire
something else well it's a good question
um it's not going to happen so this this
a possible World in which I don't give a
lot of credence that's okay um unless
you're offering Dave you know I don't
know if you have a couple billion
dollars hanging around you don't need I
I'll try to put it to good use I would
not retire I would not do that um I like
what I'm doing I want to have more time
for what I'm doing not less time I you
know maybe I would feel a little bit
less stressed about meeting a certain
book deadline or something like that but
otherwise what I'm doing is what I want
to do I don't even know if I would move
you know like we just moved into this
house it's more house than we need
frankly um I would fix the roof tomorrow
and um a couple other
mild things but given that moving is
kind of a pain and we like our house I
would probably just stay in the same
house probably stay with the same job I
could imagine yeah I don't even want to
quit my job like I I was going to say I
could imagine quitting my job and still
doing research and talking to people but
having the job um gives you certain
rights and responsibilities right like I
can do things at John's Hopkins um and I
like doing that so that's good so I'd
probably even keep my job despite the
fact that it gives me certain time
constraints and obligations and things
like that uh what I definitely would do
I mean I would definitely have a good
time I would buy some very expensive
wrist watches and nice clothes I would
suddenly show up to work in nothing but
bespoke tailoring every day and I would
uh
absolutely uh give money to a research
institute in fact I would give money to
the Natural philosophy Forum at John's
Hopkins which is uh the little thing
that Janan Ismael and I are have created
and are trying to use to promote the
idea of natural philosophy the
intersection of Science and philosophy
maybe I would make another Research
Institute also for sort of complex
systems on the east coast to mirror what
Santa Fe does in uh the Southwest um and
I would provide resources for postdocs
and and graduate students and things
like that as well as new faculty members
meanwhile depending on how super rich I
was I would try to do things like you
know cure poverty and homelessness and
cancer and things like that you know the
it's always too many things that you
need to try to do and not enough money
to do them in or or time but I wouldn't
spend a lot of you know my intellectual
effort curing homelessness uh because I
don't think that I am the person who
knows best how to do that I would put
some effort into figuring out what way
what are the best strategies for doing
it and then I would hire people who
could do it and then I would lead them
alone with my money so I have enough
money to buy my nice clothes and my nice
wristwatches otherwise um I would I
would try to do good things with it Tim
gitos says Barry lower said near the end
of your podcast with him that the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics leads us to quote take
probabilities out of the world and treat
them entirely as indexical unquote what
does this mean why does he consider it a
problem why do you not consider it a
problem yes indexical probability is
exactly the that's just the technical
term for when you know everything except
you don't know where you are
indexical means there's not only the
situation of the world but there's also
a little index or a pointer that says
and here you are in it that wouldn't be
necessary if there was only one version
of you in the world but once you have
many worlds or when you just have a big
old classical Universe there can be
multiple copies of you in the world
likewise in boltzman brain leg scenarios
or simulation arguments or whatever and
so the idea is uh in many worlds that
the reason why we think quantum
mechanics has probabilities in it and
those probabilities obey the born rule
namely that the probability is given by
the wave function squared is because
everything happens that is allowed by
the short shener equation everything
with a non-zero amplitude uh will come
to pass but they don't come to pass
equally and when when they do come to
pass you are forced to answer ask ask
the question and then answer it what is
the probability that I am in one branch
of the wave function of the Universe
versus another so that's an example of
an indexical probability I will say by
the way that uh I'm actually kind of
happy that Barry said that because I do
think that this is um something that
chip sein and I when we wrote our paper
we so Chip sein and I chip is now a a
faculty member at calch actually in the
philosophy department but he and I wrote
a paper on the born Rule and probability
in in ever Edan quantum mechanics AKA
many worlds where we really used this
idea that the probabilities in many
worlds come from indexical probabilities
or as we call them self-locating
uncertainties and we said that taking
that at face value you can derive the
born rule basically you want to not only
put probabilities on the different
places you could be but you want to do
so in a rational way you want to do so
in a way that obeys some very natural
criteria you put on and we showed that
that led to the born Rule now we were
certainly not the first to derive the
born rule in many worlds and we were
certainly not the first to point out
this this existence of self-locating
uncertainty but I do think that we tied
it together that we really you know told
a story that was more or less complete
and comprehensive You can disagree with
the story but it kind of emphasized the
fact that what those probabilities are
is indexical probabilities and that
that's not something to worry about that
it's good news not bad news because
given that fact you can derive the Bor
rule in a way so I I think that it's I
think that our approach even though it's
not the only approach does fit most
comfortably with the the question of
where do the probabilities come from in
the first place um basically my current
attitude toward it is if you think that
there are are probabilities in many
worlds at all and you think that you
should try your best in a goodfaith way
to figure out what those probabilities
would be of course they're going to end
up being the born rule there's not like
a second best possibility there's nearly
no other place you could go the real
question is why there are probabilities
at all and why there's what the nature
of those probabilities are and I think
that self-locating uncertainties or
indexical probabilities is the right
answer to that so I think that that was
a contribution that that we contributed
to as it were um Barry considers it a
problem the same reason why David Albert
considers it a problem if you go back to
my conversation with him also which is
that he doesn't think that that
qualifies as a probability or at least
it's not the traditional kind of
probability the traditional kind of
probability is you flip a coin many many
times and you notice that the coin comes
up heads half the time and Tails half
the time you look at the frequency of
the coin being flipped and you say aha
there's something I don't know about
what's going to happen next which is the
outcome of the coin flip but on the
basis of my experience I can say that
there's a certain probability based on
those frequencies so it's a frequentist
version of
probability and it seems like a little
more physical you know I so I don't
think it's the right way to think but
let's steal man it first let's you know
give the reasons why people would ever
think this way um then nice thing about
that version of probability that you
just count frequencies of things is that
it seems rigorous it seems objective it
seems out there in the world it doesn't
seem like something I invented it
doesn't seem like something that I could
have disagreed with it's a fact that in
my past history most coin flips of fair
coins are half um well all coin flips of
fair coins add up to about half heads
and about half Tails right now you
extrapolate that to the Future Maybe
there's some heavy lifting to be done by
some predispositions or some
philosophical approach etc etc but at
least it's harder to see that it was
just something you made up that it was
just you know um totally subjective
whereas the indexical probabilities you
admit from the start that it is
subjective that it is your choice that
you choose to put a certain Credence on
certain outcomes you then argue that
it's not arbitrary and this is why so
anyway I I didn't finish the the anti-
argument the anti- argument would be
that um you know the self-locating
uncertainties you just there's just no
way to do it it's just not something
that is well defined you know maybe you
could put one probability measure on
someone else puts another probability
measure on there's no way to say who's
right and who's wrong that's the
argument against it the counterargument
to that is well look like like I said
you it is true that it's subjective but
it's not arbitrary because you can ask
that your probabilities obey certain
conditions that's what chip and I did in
our paper that's what other people do
the conditions you they would like to
obey seem pretty natural the one that we
focused on which is not trivial but
nevertheless pretty reasonable seeming
is that whatever probabilities you're
putting on being in the spin up branch
of the wave function versus the spin
down Branch it shouldn't matter what's
happening elsewhere in the universe once
you've figured out what is happening in
your nearby environment uh the fact that
somebody's wearing green socks versus
purple socks a thousand miles away
should not affect your assignment to
probabilities turns out that's all you
need from that you derive the born rule
so I don't think it's a big problem I
think that you know the the real
difference is not getting the born rule
the real difference is do I need to put
a probability distribution on these
things and I think that that's just what
scientists do scientists don't know
what's going to happen next the universe
you don't know whether gravity will be
attractive tomorrow right it's been
attractive 100% of the time so far but
there's a possible world where the force
of gravity becomes repulsive tomorrow
what is the probability that you're in
that world right one way of thinking
about that question is to say well
there's different possible
worlds I don't know which one I'm in
it's an indexical probability how do I
know what what world I'm in now there
you don't have the nice rational
decision-making procedure you have with
the born rule so you're even in even
more trouble right people will disagree
you know I think the probability is 10us
3 I think it's 10us 7 and there's no
right or wrong there so that's even
worse but you can't get around it you
still have to do it in the case of many
worlds in the born rule there is a
decision procedure that gives you a
unique answer and you also still have to
do it so maybe people don't like it
maybe people you know would like it
would prefer it if it were more
objective but you don't get to choose
that's not a it's not an option that you
have you have to deal with the world as
it presents itself to
you Seth says I've been watching the TV
show devs which includes the idea that
using quantum computers they are able to
project what happens in the past and in
the future given total knowledge of the
current state of things in the universe
now and also relies on that things are
deterministic my understanding
understanding is that at the end of the
that at the quantum level things are not
deterministic but probabilistic could
you expand a little on quantum theory
and its effect of how it affects
determinism being true or not and if it
would be possible to project backwards
or forwards given enough information on
the current state of affairs sure short
answer is we don't know okay and this is
because we don't know what the right
final formulation of quantum mechanics
is there are different competing schools
of thought about what quantum mechanics
actually says some of them are perfectly
deterministic some of them are not
deterministic are are truly
indeterministic truly stochastic in some
way now one thing that we do think is
true is that
observers cannot by themselves actually
predict what they're going to see happen
next because even in the versions of
quantum mechanics that are deterministic
they always include there in the
formulation of the present state of the
universe some information that is
inaccessible to observers in the case of
a hidden variable theory that
inaccessible information is the values
of the Hidden variables in the case of
many worlds it is where you are in the
wave function but one way or the other
you cannot predict literally uh
practically even if you had infinite
information what you are going to see
next now nevertheless in both of these
theories in Hidden variables or in many
words worlds there's a God's eye view or
a lassus demon eye view which is
deterministic and everything is
perfectly predictable from the past to
the Future Etc there's also other
theories there are theories where the
wave function truly collapses
stochastically either because of a
measurement or because of some random
outcome that happens every so often or
some threshold is triggered or whatever
so we don't know but again the one thing
that we can agree on no matter what our
favorite version quantum mechanics Is
that real world observers can't do it so
for all intents and purposes as far as
actual human beings agents in the
universe are concerned the deep down
laws of physics are indeterministic not
deterministic now I'm going to group
together three questions about a deep
issue in mathematical philosophy or the
philosophy of mathematics Sandro stooky
says how can do you re re sorry how do
you reconcile being a poetic naturalist
with being a reality realist as opposed
to a mathematical realist if tables and
chairs are real because they provide a
useful way of talking about the world
then why would Vector spaces and remani
and manifolds not be real after all they
have proven to be very useful ways to
describe the world and if those are real
why not sets and numbers out of which we
construct Vector spaces
Etc Leo Bey says I was a big fan of our
mathematical Universe the book by Max
tegmark another previous mindscape guest
I like that by now the people asking the
questions are including parenthetical
notes saying previous mindscape guests
because they know that I do it all the
time in the book Leo continues he talks
about how as we look closer the basic
constituents of the universe like mass
and charge seem to only be describable
by their relations to other similar
mathematical entities are you
sympathetic to the view that the
universe is fundamentally mathematical
or do you think there's likely to be
some basic stuff with qualities that
can't be mathematically Quantified
finally P Walder says this is three
questions I'm grouping together within
the poetic naturalist view of reality
where do abstract entities such as
information knowledge and numbers fit
are such entities a category of thing
that are to be considered just as real
as matter and energy and therefore of
equal importance in accounting for the
reality we
experience so the question here is so
some of you know that I have written
this paper called reality realism it was
prompted by conversations with Justin
Clark Don yet another former mindscape
guest remember when I had Justin on the
podcast uh we were talking about
morality and Mathematics in both cases
an argument can be made that the
arguments in favor of
realism in the case of morality moral
realism says moral um judgments reflect
something objective and true and real
about the external World whereas moral
anti- realism says no we kind of make
them up um and mathematical realism you
know do the vector spaces and sets and
numbers that we use to talk about math
have an independent existence like Plato
would have us believe or are they useful
fictions that we use to describe things
and I long story short my paper put
forward the idea which is not only my
idea by any stretch um it's one of those
papers like I did it was my idea to
write the paper so sometimes you write a
paper because you have a good idea and
you want to share it with the world
other times you write a paper because
the world comes to you and says we would
like your opinion about this so anytime
you hear me talking about free will or
Consciousness or mathematical realism
I've probably been provoked to do it by
somebody else I don't do those things uh
myself you know intentionally because I
don't think that I'm the best person to
talk about them I I think I have
opinions but there's probably people who
have much more considered opinions here
than I do anyway my uh attitude was what
I think is real is the real world the
physical world um I think that the stuff
of the universe whatever that stuff is I
don't think you can say well what is the
stuff of the world that's not an
answerable question like what kind of
answer could you possibly be asking for
it's Unique it is suig generous as the
philosophers would say when they don't
want to say it's
Unique it's the one and only world that
is out there reality that's what I think
is real and all this stuff including
mathematics I I suggest is not
separately real it's a way of talking
about the stuff in the world that we
have and to be very super duper honest
here I'm not completely committed to
this this is the best I can do having
talked to people having read things
having thought about it Etc this is my
current position but it's not something
where I understand all the ins and outs
perfectly well so I'm open to changing
my mind about this if someone can
convince me otherwise I I've talked to
various people on different sides right
uh Tim modlin is a mathematical realist
jod auni is an anti-realist a nominalist
you know etc etc um so
to I guess let's let's do Leo's question
first am I sympathetic to the view that
the universe is fundamentally
mathematical or is there likely to be
some basic stuff given what I just said
I hope it's clear I think that there's
some basic stuff mathematics is a way of
describing what happens in the world
it's not the stuff of the world when
someone like Max tegmark says the world
is math I literally have no idea what
that is supposed to mean the
world is well described by certain
mathematical statements sure that I
understand but when you know every
mathematical structure is real things
like this I just the words have become
unored from their meanings in my head so
I don't know what that means I think
that physical stuff is real and math is
a way of talking about it so to get to
Sandro's question um how can I be a
poetic naturalist which is someone who
thinks that there is only one world the
physical world but many ways of talking
about it and those ways of talking about
it can be equally real so you have some
fundamental level with quarks and gluons
and some emerging level with tables and
chairs and so Sandra is suggesting that
math is a way of talking about the
universe much like tables and chairs and
therefore just as we ascribe reality to
the tables and chairs we should ascribe
reality to numbers and sets the
difference I think is I do think that
there's a difference which is that I
don't sub ascribe reality to the word
table I don't ascribe reality to the
idea of tabless I ascribe reality to
tables to an individual table there's a
table right here in front of me I
describe reality to that and likewise
when I have two apples in front of me I
can ascribe reality to the fact that
there are two apples that does not mean
I think that I have to ascribe reality
to the notion of two as an abstract
entity it is it is a way of talking but
the ways of talking I mean sometimes
probably maybe this is my fault that I
am myself talking sloppily about it if I
if I say the ways of talking are real I
hope I don't ever say that but if I do
by mistake what I mean is the levels
describe real feat teates of the world
the ways of talking about them are
vocabularies that we use to describe
those real things they are not to be
confused for the things that are real
the motto of poetic naturalism is there
is only one world the natural world the
real physical world that's what's real
so I think it's entirely compatible with
being a reality
realist I am not sure but I wonder if
reality realism is what Vicken Stein was
getting at when he said that the world
is everything that is the
famous opening line uh from binstein I
never understood what he meant by that
like what else could it be but maybe he
was getting at something like this
finally uh P walder's question I think
I've already answered it right what is
the poetic naturalist view of reality uh
Visa abstract numbers Etc you know I do
think that the reason why I am
incompletely certain um I'm never
metaphysically certain but I'm I'm I'm
nowhere near you know uh even
practically certain about this stuff is
is because I do think and Justin made a
good distinction in his book that
mathematics is
objective in other words when we
understand the the meaning of two and
plus and equals in the context of
ordinary uh addition you will always
agree that the answer is four now
there's I know there's an internet
argument about is 2 plus 2 equals 4
that's cuz I I just gave you some
footnotes that statement if you don't
agree with the conventional definition
of addition like if you're doing
addition modulo 3 then 2 plus two is not
four so it does depend on your
definitions but if you agree on the
definitions then everyone should get 2+
2 equal 4 uh that's objectively true but
as Justin argues objectivity is
different than realism there's an
outness to realism um and he has a list
of criteria of what he means by real in
this case you have to Define what you
mean and in my paper that you can find
online called reality realism I try to
pinpoint where I diverge from him in the
claim that mathematical uh Concepts have
to be real so you can look that up on
the Internet which is still working as
of today's
podcast okay going on to the next
question from loose leaf obviously you
are someone who thinks very deeply about
philosophy and have your own unique
understandings about meanings of life so
I'm curious would you apply your own
unique values to your romantic
relationship and other close
relationships in your life or would you
rather go along with or at least empath
empathize with the more popular values
that most people tend to have and if you
were to raise a child would you try to
convince him or her of your own
worldview or would you try to let him or
her explore the world freely without
exposing him or her to your
ideas so I think this is cheating
because you have more than one question
here and we do have a rule you shouldn't
have more than one question so I'm going
to sort of skip through it and and kind
of connect them um I mean of course I'm
going to follow my own values I I don't
I don't know why maybe there's some
implicit subtext here that I'm missing
why would I empathize with more popular
values that I disagreed with in a
romantic relationship or a or a
collegial relationship or a friend
relationship I mean that would be weird
if I went to all the effort to really
think through my values and find some
that for which I disagreed with the
popular conception but nevertheless
stuck with the popular conception rather
than mine in the particular context of
friendships or romance that would seem
very weird to me no I don't see any
reason to do that now that doesn't mean
that you have to be a jerk that doesn't
mean that when you disagree with people
you have to be you know impolite to them
or anything like that there are ways to
negotiate those real world situations
when it comes to having children Etc
which I do not have but uh on the one
hand I would absolutely let them try to
come up with their own worldview the
best they could on the other hand I'm
certainly going to expose them to my
ideas again why would I not do that I
don't I don't quite understand why this
question is is being asked but I I I I
worry that there is some reason why it's
being asked which is why I'm trying to
answer it um uh yeah I think that the
whole point of going through this
exercise of trying to think very hard
about what your values are etc etc means
that you should follow your values um I
guess the question is sliding back and
forth a little bit between following
your values
and telling other people about your
values usually I would do that uh but
you know it depends on there might be
social circumstances under which you
know I don't want to go into details
about my atheism for example right um or
I don't want to go into details about
whatever other choice I made the death
penalty or or something like that so I
think that you know in general if you
have values you should stick to them I
don't ever see why you should stick to
someone else's but that doesn't
necessarily mean you have to be in your
face about it I guess that's what I'm
trying to say Keith says thanks to your
AMA post patreon perk shout out so what
Keith is getting at is that when I post
the AMA answers on
patreon um I will say a little bit like
a couple of sentences not that much
believe me I don't put a lot of effort
into them all patreon supporters do get
a monthly picture of Ariel and calaban
of course usually Ariel and calaban
sometimes if I book out or something
like that I will advertise the book but
it's usually a kitty picture so there's
some little tiny miniature patreon perks
that that the uh supporters get Keith
says I'm sitting here trying to imagine
the space of all unasked questions
that's because I mentioned the other day
that despite the fact that we've gone
through a lot of questions over the
history of the amas we're still nowhere
close to filling the space of all and
asked questions for an AMA where all
questions are finite length and written
in a finite alphabet at least there's a
finite space of questions my question is
what additional constraints on this
space really narrows it down to the
Subspace of what would be considered
questions for example maybe a question
is something with a conceivable answer
or
response sadly I have no great answer to
this uh what additional constraints
really narrows it down to the Subspace
of questions I will mention that of
course even if this is just B's library
of Babel but for questions one question
that you that people raise in the
context of library of Babel is there's a
finite number of books in the library if
you didn't listen to the episode with
bully megon um we were talking about the
library Babel where every possible book
is in it so you have a finite alphabet
and you just have every single possible
concatenation of every single possible
set of letters in that alphabet so you
have every possible book and people say
well if it's finite the books have to be
of some length like 500 pages long or
whatever so you don't actually have
every book because some books are 600
pages long the answer to that is that's
just a two volume set if you have a 600
page book that can be found by including
the right first volume and the right
second volume so all the books really
are there likewise same thing goes true
for these questions even if the
questions are a finite length written in
a finite alphabet U there are not a
finite number of them because there's a
infinite number of ways you can string
together these strings of finite
questions so anyway that's just a little
footnote there um there's a very good
question that is being asked here you
know if you imagine the space well maybe
it's a good question or not the the
literal question that Keith asks is what
additional constraints really narrows it
down to the Subspace of what would be
considered
questions so what is the space that
you're narrowing down if is is it just
the space of all sequences of letters or
sequences of words or sequences of words
with a question mark after it um I think
that matters a lot so let's imagine that
what we're considering our grammatically
correct
sentences then you know that some
grammatically correct sentences take the
form of a question and some don't this
is a purely uh syntactic issue syntax as
opposed to semantics it's not about what
the words mean it's about their
grammatical relationship with each other
so the rules of grammar tell us that
certain question certain uh strings of
words take the form of a question
certain ones don't um that's little
ambiguous there you know we would like
the rules of grammar to be a little bit
more cut and dry than they really are
sometimes you can just add a question
mark to the end and get a different
sentence right if you say this is r that
sounds like a declarative sentence if
you say this is red then you're asking a
question meaning really is this red just
asked in a slightly poetic way but I
think that what you're getting at is the
issue of what does it mean to be a
question you know aside from issues of
syntax and grammar and things like that
and then yeah I unless I'm missing
something deep I think that a question
is something that in principle sets up a
possible space of allowed responses like
when you say what color is the book
cover so you know that the possible
responses are colors there's hopefully a
finite number of colors that you could
refer to when you gave your answer and
then it is it is setting up that space
of possible responses and there is a
right response or at least you know if
the question is well posed and about
something true in the world then there
could be a right response to it so
questions are about you know
setting up some uncertainty about what a
response is in a class of conceivable
responses and then looking for the right
one I don't know I just made that up so
maybe someone out there in logic land
has a better answer than I do John
showning says I've seen other sources
claim that the magnetic field is really
just a derived effect from viewing the
electric field from a different
relativistic frame if this is true can
it really be said that there is a
magnetic field fundamentally or are
there just electric fields plus
relativity you know in part this is one
of those it depends on how you want to
Define your words questions right uh let
me tell you how I would put it there is
one thing which is the electromagnetic
field one of the things that happened
when we invented relativity is that we
unified different conceptions with each
other right famously space and time were
separate before relativity came along
after relativity comes along you know
they're both part of one underlying
unified
SpaceTime less well known is the fact
that the same exact thing happens to the
electric and magnetic fields it's not
that the electric field is the real
thing anymore than space is the real
thing you haven't reduced the number uh
you haven't reduced one thing to a
pre-existing thing you have unified two
things together so it is true that if
you have an electric field and zero
magnetic field as seen by one Observer
then as seen by another Observer you
will have a different electric field and
some non-zero magnetic field but it's
also true that if you have a magnetic
field and no electric field as seen by
some Observer then to a different
Observer they will see both a non-zero
electric field and a magnetic field and
the underlying thing is a tensor field
as readers of the biggest ideas volume
one are well aware there is an
electromagnetic field strength t tensor
that uh includes both the electric field
and the magnetic field and that is the
thing that exists in some sense and how
you divide it up into electric and
magnetic fields will be Observer
dependent in exactly the same way that
how you divide SpaceTime up into space
and time will also be Observer dependent
Ru Phillips says can you talk about the
future of many worlds what would have to
be true or what Milestones do you think
will need to achieve for the majority of
the physics Community to adopt many
worlds as a proper model of foundational
physics I think there's two things going
on one is already happening which is
that you just need to appreciate the
need for a proper model of foundational
physics proper model of quantum physics
in particular you know we've been
muddling along with the Copenhagen
interpretation which is hilariously IL
defined for a very long time now but as
technology improves and as physicists
are paying more attention to truly
Quantum phenomena especially
entanglement and measurement and so
forth they are becoming easier to
convince that we need to get quantum
mechanics right so whether it's many
worlds or something else first we need
to convince physicists that it's worth
spending the effort to think carefully
about the foundations of quantum
mechanics the other is you know why many
worlds versus anything else and I do
think that physicists are relentlessly
practical at the end of the day the
thing that will make many worlds very
popular
is to convince people to demonstrate
that it helps that thinking about
quantum physics in this language
actually helps you solve other problems
I think that's true and so I think that
will become more and more clear uh it's
not quick it's not like next year it's
going to happen or anything like that
but I I I think that even though many
worlds does help you solve problems
there's no killer app as of yet there's
no case you can point to which you can
say like look how enormous ly clearer
this is in many worlds than in other
areas there are some pretty uh pretty
clear examples to me like the delayed
Choice Quantum eraser that I once wrote
about on my blog how enormously easier
it is to understand in many worlds than
in conventional Copenhagen kind of
language I'm what I'm really hoping for
is understanding something in Quantum
field Theory or quantum gravity uh that
just makes so much more sense if many
worlds is the case now I don't know what
that thing is so maybe it won't happen
but if that does happen then the rest of
the community I think will eventually
come
along Nick C says when one thinks back
in time toward the Big Bang there's
probably a lot of agreement back until
at least Electro week unification but as
you go further back there's presumably a
lot less agreement and experimental
observational proof and things get more
speculative how do you think one should
address this when communicating with the
public who don't necessarily know what's
speculative and what's not it seems like
sometimes scientists speaking to the
public will talk about their own highly
speculative idea in the same manner as
ideas that are much more
established yeah that's true and I guess
I think scientists should be
honest I think that it's I get why
they're not and they're not dishonest in
the sense that they're saying something
they know to be wrong it is absolutely
true that scientists are a little vague
sometimes about ideas that are clearly
on the right track versus ideas that are
just very very promising versus ideas
that many people don't agree with but
they think are right you know I think
that um you have to be clear about those
different possibilities it's a service
to the people you're talking to but it
also slows you down and can be confusing
right um like like you'll hear me over
and over again I've already done it
several times in this AMA when people
ask questions about quantum mechanics I
have to stop and say well it depends on
your view of the fun fundamental
foundations of quantum mechanics right
and that's
enormously um I don't want to say
irritating maybe a little bit irritating
but it certainly slows you down uh when
I wrote volume two of the biggest ideas
in the universe the whole philosophy of
the biggest ideas books is I'm going to
teach you ideas that are more or less
accepted and will continue to be
accepted for the next 500 years okay in
the same way that Newtonian mechanics is
still accepted today not that it's
fundamental not that it's perfect we
know that there are cases where it
doesn't work but there's also cases
where it still does work you can get to
the moon perfectly well with Newtonian
mechanics and that will always be the
case there will always be the case that
Newtonian mechanics Works in its domain
of applicability so for the biggest
ideas those are the ideas I wanted to
focus on and that's why I did not want
to spend a lot of time talking about
different foundations of quantum
mechanics theories but what that meant
was I had to talk about things I it was
I was threatening to get bogged down
when I'm talking about Quantum fields or
wave functions or virtual particles or
whatever and every single time I have to
like add a paragraph saying well you
could say this or you could say that or
you could say something else so
ultimately I just for the most part
chose a perspective where I said look
here is my way of talking about quantum
mechanics I will let know right here and
now that other people disagree and here
is the way in which they disagree but
I'm going to assume it for the rest of
the book okay but at least I was that
obvious uh that honest whereas I do
agree when people when it comes to the
early Universe um we have a pretty good
theory but parts of it are speculative
inflation being the most obvious idea of
something that is still speculative we
don't have cut and dried evidence that
it's on the right track it's not at that
level of Newtonian mechanics we don't
know whether the universe inflated at
the end of the day and I do think that
as a shortcut some people talk as if we
do so I don't think I do I try not to
anyway um you know I try to be honest
about what we know and what we don't and
by the way this isn't just scientists
talking to the popular press either or
or popular audiences they talk that way
to each other right they say like well
during inflation this must have happened
but the difference is that they all know
how what level of uncertainty they
should they should put on it and maybe
someone thinks that inflation is 90%
likely to happen and someone else thinks
it's 40% but they can talk to each other
and they can say like they can translate
into oh if inflation happened then this
might must have happened whereas to a
popular audience they might not be able
to do that translation because like you
are implying they don't know which parts
are perfectly well established and which
which parts are not even when you you go
back to the time of Electro week
unification that is um a much earlier
time and a much higher temperature than
we actually have data about in the early
Universe okay so there's the reason why
people act for some justification pretty
confident about what happened at those
Early times is because we have particle
physics experiments we do have some data
about what the laws of physics were like
like back then okay that comes from the
large hron collider and other particle
physics experiments Etc but we don't
have direct cosmological data about that
so it's absolutely possible that the
actual time of the electro week phase
transition was one where the
cosmological situation was pretty
different than we think it probably was
the actual time when we have the
earliest empirical evidence in the
universe is Big Bang nucleosynthesis
that's between a second and a few
minutes after the big bang I wrote a
paper once with Manoj kapling hat where
we said what if it were different you
know are we really sure like a lot of
people take the standard
model of not not just of particle
physics but also cosmology Etc and they
say well if you had more neutrinos or
more dark matter whatever how
constrained is that by
nucleosynthesis and what monogan I did
is just say let's say we don't take the
standard model let's just say we have an
expanding Universe we take the standard
model of particle physics but not
cosmology so not general relativity Etc
what do we know about how the universe
was expanding at that time so not just
the rate of expansion but the rate of
change of expansion and actually the
answer is we're pretty
constrained we it at that time when you
were making uh heavy nuclei sorry light
nuclei like helium lithium dyum there's
enough experimental data that you can't
do anything dramatically different from
the standard picture in in terms of both
the expansion rate and how it is
evolving over time but before that you
know that's a temperature of what me
millions of electron volts the electro
week transition is hundreds of billions
of electron volts so that's a lot higher
temperature we don't know what the
universe was doing back then but we can
talk about it with some confidence
because we have particle physics data
but you know to be honest you don't
really know for sure
Brendan says I realize you have a few
trade books and a textbook in the works
have you ever considered writing science
books for children I think you have an
amazing ability to comp to convey
complex Concepts in a way that is easy
to understand and that seems like it
would help to make really good science
Children books uh I've not really taken
that idea seriously no um I mean I take
lots of ideas casually non seriously the
number of books I've contemplated
writing is truly enormous in in size I'm
not at all sure that I would be good at
it at least I'm not sure that I would be
good enough at it to be better than
anyone else right um I think that my
value added is much more on the other
side like I think that I can actually
even in my popular books within the span
of popular books my popular books are
more towards the serious side right a
little bit more detail a little bit more
um you know even my book on the bow on
which is probably my most popular book
there you know once you get 2third of
the way through there's gaug invariance
and symmetry breaking and things like
that and I've had more than one person
say like I really like the book up until
then and then it became hard uh and
maybe that's just me maybe if I just
forced myself to do better at it I could
but i' like that I'd like you know
working at that edge where I'm going to
push you a little bit I'm going to you
know assume that you're pretty smart
you're motivated and and I want you to
you know stretch your brain a little bit
that's my favorite place to be so that's
usually where I am but you know who
knows I've changed my mind
before Jeffrey seagull says in the past
I've read speculations about
manipulating black holes by making them
charged and then moving them using
electric Fields however I gather that
electric interactions can be expressed
in terms of exchanges of photons I was
curious then how to imagine the photon
exchanges with black holes if nothing
ever leaves the black hole except for
Hawking radiation
do all the interactions of a black hole
with an electric field involve photons
getting trapped by the black hole
independent of whether the black hole is
being repelled or attracted by an
external electric field I think there's
various ways to answer this question but
the short answer is do not think of
electric interactions as being expressed
in terms of exchanges of photons there
are certain circumstances under which
that's something you can do um like when
an electron and a positron scatter off
of each other in a scattering experiment
then you have findan diagrams and you
calculate with exchanges of photons it
all makes perfect sense but when you
have a single particle that is just
sitting there with a static field around
it a so-called kulum field because it's
kum's law that says the electrical field
Force goes as one over the inverse
distance
squared then a static field surrounding
a single particle is not easily
described not naturally described in
terms of photons you absolutely can do
it no problem doing it if you just want
to run through the math it doesn't give
you the direct intuition that you get
just by thinking of it in terms of a
classical field sitting around the the
particle and the same thing is exactly
true for black holes right I mean black
holes have a gravitational field and
guess what you can think of that
gravitational field as AR rising from
the exchange of gravitons it's not the
natural way to think about it in that
context it's it's not easy it doesn't
help you understand anything but if you
really were dedicated to doing that you
could likewise with the electric field
around a black hole it's just much
easier to think of the electric field
around a black hole don't torture
yourself by turning it into photons
black holes can have electric Fields you
have electric lines of force they enter
the black hole there you go the black
hole has an electric field in fact think
of it this way there is 's law which
says that if I have some region of space
and I take the electric field that goes
through the boundary of the region so
some three-dimensional region of space
some boundary of that region which is
kind of like spherical in topology but
it might be lumpy who cares doesn't
matter I have a boundary that is a
two-dimensional boundary and there's an
electric field there may may not be an
electric field but there could be an
electric field sort of going through the
boundary at different points and gauss's
law says the total electric field
escaping through that boundary is
proportional to the amount of electric
charge inside right so this is most
obviously interesting and important if
you just have a single particle you can
integrate the electric field and a
little sphere that is nearby the
particle and you get an answer how much
electric field is coming out through the
sphere very close to the particle then
you consider a different sphere far away
from the particle but still no other
particles have enter or left so you
still only have that one particle and
you can integrate the electric field
around that bigger sphere at any one
point on the bigger sphere there's much
less electric field because you're
further away from the particle but
there's a lot more area to that sphere
it's bigger and those two effects
exactly cancel each other out that's
what gauss's law tells you so just by
counting the electric field in a region
you know how much charge is
inside now imagine that I have a bunch
of electric charge inside and it
collapses to a black hole gauss's law
doesn't care that it's a that it's a
black hole it says far away you can
count up all the electric field add it
up and you find out how much charge is
inside and that you get a very similar
issue in um gravity you get exactly the
same kind of thing you can figure out
how much mass is inside the region so
these long range forces of gravity and
electromagnetism exist out side of uh
whatever particle or object you're
talking about and that's just as true
for black holes as for anything else
therefore yes you could absolutely
imagine charging up a black hole and
using that to move it around in fact you
don't even need to charge it up you
could use could move it around just
using gravity if you were really good at
it but electromagnetism is much easier
to manipulate so that might be a smart
idea I'm going to group together these
two questions Dylan Hall says is there
any explanation at all for three
generations of matter and specifically
why it's only Fons and not bons even
though some bons have mass is it
inherent in the P Exclusion Principle
somehow it feels like there's an
important connection that I'm missing
and Kevin oul says is there evidence
against quarks heavier than top quarks
or are there theoretical arguments
against them naively it seems more
natural to have an infinite series of
ever heavier particles than to have
exactly three levels of quarks and so
both questions are about more quarks and
leptons Beyond what we've actually
already
seen so we don't know a once and for all
fundamental reason why there are three
generations of matter so what's being
referred to here is forgetting about the
bons forgetting about the quarks sorry
the gluons the photons the w and z the
graviton the hegs Bon forgetting about
those those are all Force carrying boson
particles the matter particles of the
standard model of particle physics fall
into this nice structure of generations
that is to say there is a quark with a
charge plus 2/3 the up Quark there's a
charge a quark with charge minus 1/3 the
down Quark there is a lepton that is to
say not a quark a particle that does not
feel the strong force there's a lepton
with a charge minus one the electron and
there is a neutral lepton on the
electron nutrino so those are four
particles up Quark down Quark electron
nutrino and that pattern of those four
particles repeats two other times
there's a heavier generation with charm
and strange quark muan and muan neutrino
and a yet heavier generation with bottom
and and top Quark to lepton and uh to
nutrino and then that's it there's no
even heavier ones okay that we know
about I think that there's not
absolutely
100% uh evidence that there isn't a
heavier generation people have certainly
looked look it's let's just put it this
way whenever you ask a question like
this it's good to ask these questions by
all means you should Wonder but probably
particle physicists have thought of this
already so probably people have thought
about it and there is a reason why
either we haven't seen it or we're not
trying very hard so people have
certainly thought about heavier
generations of firon
they are they tend to be complete
generations and there are reasons for
that that get a little subtle uh the
most obvious one is something called
anomaly
cancellation and I'm not going to get
the details right on this for you um but
just so you know that there's something
out there you know that all these
particles all these Fons interact
through gauge forces right through
forces carried by photons and gluons and
wz bosons and all these are related to
symmetry
that's why they are gauge forces I feel
I feel I can use these big words because
I know that in May you're going to be
buying Quant and Fields biggest ideas
volume two and you will learn about what
all these words mean like gauge theories
and and things like that so it turns out
that as I've said many times before the
way that we generally go about
constructing quantum mechanical theories
is to start with a classical Theory and
quantize it you don't have to do that um
but that's typically what physicists do
so it also turns out that when you start
with a gauge Theory a symmetry group
that gives rise to some bons there's a
danger that when you quantize it the
Symmetry will be
broken symmetries can be broken in the
real world and it's okay but only under
certain carefully controlled
circumstances and I again I won't go
into what all the details are the kinds
of breaking that is purely quantum
mechanical there's a kind of symmetry
breaking that purely comes from the
process of quantizing a classical
symmetry that is called an anomaly a
Quantum anomaly in the classical
Symmetry and if it's a gauge symmetry
anomalies are bad you don't want to
break truly fundamentally really your
gauge symmetry when you go from a
classical symmetry to a Quantum Symmetry
and what that means is there's only
certain combinations of particles that
are allowed because you can calculate
what the anomaly will be and if the
anomaly is not zero then you're in
trouble a theory like the standard model
of particle physics in each generation
the anomalies exactly cancel so there's
like a number you calculate and it gets
a contribution from the electron and the
neutrino and the up quark and the down
quark and then that number you want to
be zero and it is good thing to
calculate as a little homework problem
if you're a graduate student studying
Quantum field Theory and because it it
cancels for each each generation it will
also cancel for three generations right
doesn't matter you just 3 * 0 is still
zero but if you try to add some subset
of particles like I'm going to add a new
positively charged Quark you're running
in big danger of creating an anomaly
where there wasn't any and therefore
ruining your gauge symmetry so there
might be other clever ways to cancel it
it's not an argument that you have to
work Generation by generation but it's
certainly the safest way to work and if
that's true then if you have a heavier
Quark you will also have leptons that go
along with it as part of the generation
including neutrinos and those would
probably be light right and we haven't
seen those yet so that's a good reason
to think that there just aren't any
heavier particles he heavier Fons than
the ones that we know about it has
nothing to do with the p Exclusion
Principle just so you're there um the
other thing is uh is it natural to have
an infinite series of every ever heavier
particles it's actually not that natural
and the reason why is because the word
heavier is is doing something here the
word heavier means that you're talking
about particles that have mass and all
of these particles that we're talking
about the top Quark Etc these all get
Mass from the higs mechanism from the
fact that the higs Bon has a non-zero
expectation value in empty space and so
all of these particle masses are given
by some dimensionless number some
coupling constant called the yukawa
coupling times the expectation value of
the higs boson and the heaviest of them
the top Quark is pretty close it's like
one times the expectation value the higs
Bon that's not exactly true but it's of
order one the electron is much lighter
Etc you don't
expect particles that get their Mass
from the higs boson to have masses much
higher than the higs expectation value
and therefore it makes sense that the
top Quark is where it should be
everything else is a little bit lighter
but there's no obvious reason why you
would want to go even heavier than that
you could you could imagine doing it but
it wouldn't be the most natural thing in
the
world okay AJ says I think you said
something to the effect that Free Will
is real but not fundamental that makes
sense to me right now but assuming we
are at some Future Point able to EXP
explain the macro phenomenon of Free
Will from whatever constitutes it would
it still be right to call it free will
that is doesn't the compatibilist
position break down at some point sure
absolutely no worries about that but
guess what I don't think it's going to
happen you know philosophers physicists
neuroscientists they sometimes like to
Grant themselves thought experiment
omniscience right like what if we were
lassus demon what if we knew everything
that was going on in the brain Etc what
if from some amount of data that we
could store on a hard drive we could
predict everything a human being could
do okay you're not it's not going to
happen the human brain has 85 or 86 I
forget the number billion neurons in it
and they are connected to each other in
many many many many connections so the
actual number of Connections in the
brain the connectome as it is called is
way bigger than 85 billion okay it's I I
don't know what the number is trillions
and trillions and trillions so the idea
that somehow you would have enough
information to predict what that brain
is going to do next is not a very good
idea it's not very promising I would say
I could be wrong about that uh there's
no law of physics that says it couldn't
happen uh it's pretty close because it's
not just the state of the brain but the
brain is not a closed system right the
brain is interacting with the body the
body is interacting with the world and
so you need to be constantly updating
your 85 billion neurons and all their
connections to really know what the
brain is doing but yeah in principle you
could imagine knowing enough to be able
to predict exactly what someone's going
to do without the need for talking about
things like Free Will and choices Etc in
exactly the same way that you know you
could predict where the billiard balls
are going to go on a billiard table by
knowing exactly what every molecule of
the felt and the billiard balls and
everything were doing it's not practical
it's not going to happen I'm not worried
about it like in the list of things to
worry about that's just not on my list
but yes it could happen in in
principle even then even if that did
happen I think it's still extremely
possible that it wouldn't be worth it
right that it's still true that we can
talk about human beings as agents making
choices
in an enormously more efficient way and
so maybe there's some special conditions
under which you really want to read out
the state of every neuron and every
connection between neurons in the human
brain but it just isn't worth the effort
usually right and in that case once
again you would talk about people having
free will Spencer haras says if a photon
of light hits a telescope's CCD what was
the shape of its wave function right
before that is it the surface of a
sphere or hemisphere the radius of the
distance to the star well it depends you
got to be you got to think very
carefully about this it depends on
whether or not you want to treat this in
a spherical cow kind of way in an
otherwise empty Universe if you have a
star and nothing in between the star and
us here on Earth then yes absolutely the
wave function of the photon was in a
kind of a spherical shell it could be
distorted a little bit depending on
exactly the process that made it but
usually roughly spherical as it spreads
Across the Universe now now what would
prevent that from happening what would
uh distort that is whether it was in
some sense measured along the way which
by which we mean interfered or
interacted with the environment enough
to become decohered that's actually
pretty easy to do uh photons interact
fairly readily with charged particles
and there's a lot of charged particles
out there in the universe the problem is
that there these charged particles out
there in the universe are fair Fairly
thinly spread out here's the here's the
thing when we're in ordinary quantum
mechanics here on Earth in a laboratory
the reason why the Copenhagen
interpretation kind of sloppiness works
so well is because there's a pretty cut
and dri distinction between the
microscopic realm where there's just a
small number of particles and the
particles rarely interact with each
other you can keep one particle from
getting decohered if you want to versus
the macroscop world where there's
avagadro's number of particles some huge
number of particles in a typical
macroscopic system and therefore it's
pretty clear when a tiny system becomes
entangled with its environment the
environment is so big and uh either it
isn't Tangled or it isn't roughly
speaking so it's pretty cut and dried
when a Quantum superp position has been
measured out there in space that's no
longer true because in principle the
there's there's not a sharp distinction
between having been measured or having
decohered and not it's a gradual thing
in principle if you only had a few
particles in your system then you could
be a little bit decohered in some sense
and that's kind of the situation you're
in out there in space I don't know the
numbers so I don't know actually you
know how many interactions actually
happen with that Photon I bet it is a
lot actually so I bet it is effectively
decohered long before it gets to us in
which case the wave function would not
really be a sphere would already sort of
be focused in the direction which we are
seeing it but honestly that's a
quantitative question and I don't really
quite know the quantities sorry about
that some dude says are you a gamer of
any sort video games tabletop Sports
whatever um I was an old school
gamer in the sense that you know I grew
up begging my mom for quarters so we
could go to Spaceport and play asteroids
and centipede and Space Invaders and I
got the original Atari when it came out
and would play Adventure and other
things the various tank games that they
had but you know one changes over the
course of one's life and I'm not doing
that much gaming anymore I do play poker
although I don't uh I haven't played
poker live in a casino probably since
the pandemic uh both because at first
there wasn't any and then I got busy
moving across the country so um not not
as many casinos around here in Baltimore
as there were in Los
Angeles but uh and then I also just play
cheap little games on my iPhone or iPad
to while away the time just to take a
break from doing science or or thinking
too hard uh but nothing serious nothing
that a real gamer would recognize as
gaming ah mod chaker says is there a
deeper physical reason why there are no
massless
Fons I guess that depends what you mean
by a deep physical reason you know
masslessness having a mass equals zero
is not the generic situation right
there's only one value of mass which is
zero but there's an infinite number of
values of mass that are not zero I think
what you would expect in Quantum field
theory is that most particles have a
mass unless there's some really good
reason for them not to typically some
symmetry that is preventing a mass from
existing so for things like gravitons
and photons and gluons there are
symmetries that prevent those particles
from having Mass that's why they're
massless for Fons gen the fion that we
have in the standard model are a special
case actually they're pretty light you
know compared to the plank scale or
whatever so there's even though they're
not zero Mass there's still a question
to be asked as to why there's so light
in the first place why isn't their Mass
much larger than it could be and the
answer there is that there is a symmetry
that in principle could prevent them
from getting a mass the chyal Symmetry
the difference between well a symmetry
that acts differently between the
left-handed part of the particle and the
right Ed part the part that is spinning
clockwise with respect to its direction
of motion versus counterclockwise with
respect to its direction of motion so if
you treat those two parts separately as
is done in the standard model the su2
part of su3 su2 cross U1 acts on
left-handed particles not on
right-handed particles then you can
prevent particles from getting a mass
that's why you need the higs mechanism
the higs mechanism breaks the Symmetry
and allows you to regive the particle a
mass that they would have generally had
uh if you hadn't had that symmetry in
the first place so as I think I said in
the last Ama or or somewhere I remember
saying it's not true that the higs boson
or the higs mechanism is in general
necessary to explain the existence of
something called Mass okay they're not
related you can have mass without the
higs mechanism you cannot have mass even
with the higs mechanism like the photon
still has mass it didn't lose that
masslessness just when the higs boson
got its expectation value it's a
specific feature of this specific Theory
the standard model of particle physics
where you need the higs Bose on to give
particles masses so there's no
connection to the higs and gravity or
inertia or anything like that it's a
completely different set of
ideas go mazant says under Multiverse
Theory are all possible truths real
short answer is no uh but longer answer
is it depends guess what on what you
mean by Multiverse Theory there's
different Multiverse theories there is
the cosmological Multiverse where you
just have regions far away where
conditions look very very different
clearly there not all possible truths
are real I mean it depends by possible
truth also but there's no reason why in
a cosmological Multiverse you need to
have for example regions where space is
six-dimensional maybe you do that's
absolutely possible but it's not
necessary and we honestly don't know
it's not something that you have to have
be true then there is the many worlds of
quantum mechanics and again you don't
get all possible truths you get what is
predicted by the shortener equation uh
of course you can always go backwards
after the fact and Define the word
possible as what the shortener equation
gives you and in that case you get it
but there are plenty of configurations
of stuff that just the shortener
equation doesn't lead to so you don't
get it but there's also the possible the
Multiverse Theory called modal realism
where you think that all possible worlds
exist this is a favorite of philosophers
like David Lewis and and Max tegmark has
a version of it so there by definition
yes all possible truths are real there
is in my mind an enormous difference
between the sort of possible world's
ontology versus the cosmological or
Quantum multiverses namely that in the
physics case cases in the cosmology or
Quantum cases there is a mechanism that
generates the Multiverse there are
equations that tell you you start from
this position and you make a Multiverse
whereas in the possible worlds ontology
you're just positing that all possible
worlds exist because I don't know it
makes you feel better for some reason so
I I put a lot less Credence on that uh
version myself but if it were true then
all possible truth would be
real Blake braier says do you collect or
have ever bought original artwork such
as paintings or sculptures if so how do
you go about finding the artwork you'd
like to acquire and where do you keep it
um I don't depends on again I hate to be
all prity here all the time but depends
me like collect I own a couple of pieces
of you know actual paintings that a
human being painted onto a canvas with a
paintbrush um I'm trying to think how
many not too many Jennifer uh years ago
was very good friends with an artist uh
Adam s sitanovich I'm going to not
pronounce his name correctly I never met
him but uh he was a pretty successful
artist and she helped him with various
things and got paid in paintings so she
has a couple paintings of his um and we
purchased a couple paintings along the
way as we got older uh one by Nash hyen
who uh did a whole series on the
periodic table so different uh paintings
devoted to different or devoted to is
too strong inspired by different
elements of the periodic table so we own
gatal lium in our living room and you
know one I picked up in Paris for a
couple hundred bucks uh that just looks
pretty I don't know who did it Etc so I
wouldn't call us collectors in any
serious way um you know we don't have an
agenda we we don't go out looking for
specific things and uh you know trying
to build up some comprehensive set of
things in any genre or artist or
anything like that we just have walls in
our house that we like to put paintings
on sometimes um they're original
paintings and sometimes not depending on
what we have to you know fill the wall
at that time so uh as to where you know
we we now are in a bigger house because
we moved to Baltimore and so we have
more wall space so in principle we can
put more paintings up there uh we
haven't really gotten around to that you
know it's more like the money that we
have is being poured into keeping the
house from falling down that's an
exaggeration we're we're renovating the
house you know it's a 100-year old house
it needs some tender loving care and
it's almost there we're you know we're
very very close to having it uh be in
very good shape the roof is going to
need to be done at some point so hanging
paintings on the walls has been less of
a of a high priority there um I can I
can mention the two ways I do like to
look at paintings and contemplate buying
them um there are some excellent places
online like sa.com uh and there's
another one I'm going to get the name
but it's a wonderful resource you know
you can put in here's a how big I want a
painting to be here's how much I'm
willing to pay here's the primary color
that I like here is the subject of the
painting right and it'll pop up with
original artworks by people around the
world that fit these criteria uh maybe
you want to spend a couple hundred bucks
maybe you want to spend a couple
hundred, bucks that depends on you but
um and you know you can do your best
like they have zoomed in in pictures you
can see what it looks like up close and
then it they put it in context and
everything so I I think that there's
plenty of room for many more people to
you know once you you're past the
struggling graduate student stage of
your life if you can afford a little bit
you absolutely can own um some nice
paintings for your walls and the other
place of course is in Santa Fe when I go
to visit Santa Fe that's one of the
world centers for art galleries and
things like that and those will be a
little bit pricier in general but it's
nice to look around there's a place
called Canyon Road in Santa Fe which
basically both sides of the road for I
don't know a mile or two are nothing but
our galleries which is wonderful with
original art of all different kinds I
encourage anyone who visit Santa Fe to
check that
out Alex Miller says are there any works
of literature which you have found
genuinely productive in thinking about
the nature of fundamental reality the
boraste story clone ukar orbis titius
which you discussed in your most recent
episode was one such story for me as
well as one I came to after Leonard
susin praised it at the outside of a
lecture at the outside of a lecture
kafka's investigations of a dog you know
I don't think so at least I don't have
any off the top of my head um this is a
situation
where it's very very possible that I
read a story years ago and it did
actually affect my view of the
fundamental nature of reality and I've
forgotten I have to confess I've
confessed this before I'm very very bad
at remembering stories that I read even
movies that I've watched TV shows
whatever like you know the plots and
things like that of stories I love
reading and I love watching and I don't
remember I don't know why it is so very
very possible I will nevertheless I'll
give two examples neither one of which
relates to the fundamental nature of
reality but they're they're vaguely um
within the realm of stories that I do
remember and I bring up when when
certain topics uh come together one is
uh in Julian barnes's novel history of
the universe in 10 and a half chapters
there's a wonderful chapter about heaven
which I'm sure I've talked about before
on the podcast and spoiler alert but
I'll tell you what it what basically the
uh upshot of it is which is that uh you
won't actually enjoy being Immortal
forever that's the that's the
fundamental aspect of reality sort of
Point that he's trying to make so you
might think it'd be great to be in
heaven and be alive forever and and
enjoy yourself but it's much harder than
you think and of course that theme was
rehearsed once again more recently in
the TV show the good place if you watch
the good place uh you'll get a similar
vibe from that and then the other story
that is relevant to my thinking about
the world is Isaac asimov's Foundation
Trilogy which is not not for the reasons
you might think you know we had David
goyer on the podcast he's the one who uh
is turning Foundation into a TV series
it's there's no way to turn the
foundation into a TV series so he is
very Loosely adapting it and that is
getting people mad if they want an exact
adaptation but an exact adaptation would
be horrible in my in my view so he is
wisely changing the story in certain
important ways but the story involves
the idea of psycho history the idea that
you can kind of Imagine an analogy
between
thermodynamics and sociology or
psychology or political science or
history or whatever you want to call it
the the analogy being that in
thermodynamics you can get rules
governing the collective behavior of
billions of particles even though you
don't know the specific details of every
individual particle whereas asol wants
to say the same thing could happen with
human beings you don't know the
individual behavior of every individual
human being but nevertheless you might
be able to come up with psycho history
with a set of quantitative rules
governing the evolution of society
because there's so many people and their
little idiosyncrasies average out the
reason why this is important to me is
because it's wrong
because I get it when I read the story
when I was much much younger I thought
that was a brilliant idea I I loved it
now I know better that's not a good
analogy between human beings and atoms
because human beings are individually
complex whereas atoms are not so there's
a new possibility that opens up in the
collective behavior of human beings
which is nonlinearities small tiny
changes can actually amplify and grow to
enormous changes on the large scale in a
way that just can't happen for atoms and
thermodynamics and things like that so
it's an important cautionary tale uh and
that's just as important as an important
Insight Mike Meyer says what is the
least interesting research project you
have worked on or are there any
publications of yours that you're not
very fond of anymore I guess I'm still
fond of everything you know I put some
effort into every research project that
I've worked on some have um you know
there's different ways in which a
research project can be a success right
one of my absolute favorite research
projects to work on was on closed Tim
like Curves in general relativity I
wrote a couple of papers with Eddie fari
and Alan Guth and Ken Olam and
especially you we wrote a short paper at
the beginning to give a basic answer
saying why in 2 plus onedimensional
gravity so gravity in flatland basically
um which is a a simplification of three
plus one dimensional gravity with
infinitely long parallel cosmic strings
there was a a paper by Richard got an
astrophysicist who pointed out that you
could get closed timik curves if the
cosmic strings were moving fast enough
and um we proved that you could only do
that if they were sort of cooked into
the universe from the start basically if
there was enough angular momentum in the
original configuration of cosmic strings
then you would get that closed Tim like
curves but they would have been there
all along you weren't making them out of
nothing and in fact we showed that you
couldn't make them out of nothing and
this was I I had a great time working on
this paper there was some I contributed
some like very nice insights Etc and it
just didn't make like no one cares
really like no one was really moved to
imagine that they were worried that you
were going to make closed time light
curves from infinitely long parallel
cosmic strings so no one paid a lot of
attention to it uh but I've had other
papers where I put a lot of work in no
one cared and I in retrospect I was like
yeah should I really put that much work
into it again I liked it I liked doing
it in the moment and I thought that the
work that we did was good for example a
series of papers I wrote with W Taylor
and Miguel Ortiz on two-dimensional
quantum gravity using dynamical
triangulations um we especially wty
who's really good at this uh wty is the
nickname for Washington Taylor uh who's
a professor at MIT now and uh came up
with some very clever techniques for um
doing these matrix model versions of
ukian quantum gravity in two Dimensions
putting matter on them so they could
couple in different ways showing there
were phase Transitions and things like
that and uh yeah nobody cared we did so
much work on that and nobody cared and I
cared in the sense that I liked doing it
and I I thought it was fun while we were
doing it but it wasn't part of my bigger
research agenda right it didn't lead to
anything for me personally and I think
that it was actually a valuable lesson
you know I I say this all the time to my
own students I probably said it here on
the podcast but at some point in your
training as a scientist you go from not
being able to write papers to being able
to write papers and that's a hugely
important transition and you can be very
happy and proud of it but there's
another transition to go to which is to
write the papers that you should write
the pap papers that matter the papers
that have an impact and make a
difference and are building up to
something more important and rather than
just writing papers because you can
write them and it would be kind of cool
right because despite what you might
think when you're 25 years old you don't
have Infinity years ahead of you you
have to pick and choose what are the
papers that you have to put um your
effort into what are the what are the
papers that are worthwhile to do that um
a more recent example for me would be
it's not very recent but I wrote a with
Mark trodden and Kim body that we were
very proud of on strongly interacting
dark matter we had this idea when dark
matter is strongly interacting it's
astrophysically interesting because
maybe it changes details about Galaxy
structure or large scale structure or
clusters of galaxies or something like
that so people have been playing around
with this idea for a long time but if
the if the dark matter is strongly
interacting then you naively do not
predict the right Relic abundance right
the whole idea of weakly interacting
massive particles is that the weak
interactions give you the right strength
of interactions to get the right amount
of dark matter at the end of the day so
a lot of these scenarios just played
fast and loose with that fact they just
posited the right amount of dark matter
and let it be strongly interacting later
and we were I think a little bit more
careful about that and we really thought
about it how could you get the right
Relic abundance at at late times even
though the dark matter is strongly
interacting and so we had a mechanism
where it was weakly interacting at Early
times and strongly interacting at later
times and this was a huge amount of work
to make sure that we calculated
everything right and avoided all the
constraints from experiments and things
like that and again Kim who was the grad
student at the time she's now a
professor at University of Texas but she
did a lot of the work here and for
nothing like nobody cared about this
paper I'm a little shocked that nobody
cared about it I thought that was very
much in the mainstream of thing that
people cared about um but that even
though and I and I don't mean anything
against Mark and Kim who are two of my
favorite people in the world but that
paper like ended my career as a particle
cosmologist I'm sorry uh it just made me
realize like okay if I only do have a
finite number of hours left to do
research in my life I'm going to do it
on things that I care about more deeply
than this so it's not that there are
papers that you're not very fond of but
it's at papers you learn from in the
sense of I I could better spend my time
doing something else let me put it that
way Nita s says do you see a future
where the basics of quantum mechanics
would be incorporated in school's
curriculum uh by which I mean maybe
maybe you mean high school or I don't
know uh college for non-physics Majors
you know I I don't have strong feelings
either way honestly um I don't think you
can do it right I don't think you can do
quantum mechanics quantitatively at a at
the high school level uh I mean you
could if you dropped everything right I
mean you could use my upcoming book
Quant and Fields in the biggest ideas in
the universe or something like that and
you could say okay we're going to give
make you more or less comfortable with
the basics of calculus and uh complex
numbers and things like that and and
teach you enough quantum mechanics to
solve the short Ander equation I think
you could do that for high school
students if you did nothing else if you
taught them no other math and physics
and just devoted yourself to doing that
um but you don't want to do that I don't
think you there's other things to learn
in in high school you have to pick and
choose so if you were going to do
quantum mechanics at all it would be
more handwavy and more like giving
people an impression of some of the
ideas of modern physics now even though
I just said that in a slightly
dismissive way I actually think that's a
perfectly good idea I do think that
forgetting about the specific iics of
quantum mechanics I think that when you
teach high school students physics it
need not be just a super watered down
version of physics 101 right where you
teach pendulums going back and forth and
incline planes and all that stuff
there's no reason why you can't teach
high school students or pre high school
students for that matter things about
relativity and quantum mechanics and
black holes and the Big Bang um or for
that matter you know super conductivity
or the structure of atoms or whatever is
your favorite Topic in physics these
people are mostly not going to grow up
to be physicists there's no reason why
their physics education should be just
the watered down version of Newtonian
mechanics um but on the third hand I do
not know a lot about the high school
curriculum and I shouldn't really say
what should be in it because there's
always unintended consequences right
there's always um things that are a
certain way for certain reasons that
maybe we've forgotten so people who are
much more expert than I should say
whether or not that would actually work
to uh get people excited about physics
at a young age ell and Lucas Wagner say
this is about the last section of
something deeply hidden you mentioned
that time and space might be emerging
from something else do you have any
thoughts or ideas on how one might
represent uh as opposed to I'm not quite
sure if I'm reading this question
correctly how one might represent a wave
function from which space and time is
emergent well I think that's the
interesting thing um you shouldn't is
the short answer in other words when we
start with wave functions uh this is why
I stumbled reading the question because
there's a parenthetical that says as
opposed to position momentum Etc what
this means is when we start with wave
functions we think about the wave
function of a particle as a function of
some observable quantity or set of
quantities okay so we think of a wave
function as a function of position or a
function of momentum or a function of
spin various things you could then
observe about it and then the value of
the wave function for each observable
quantity squared gives you the
probability so I think the question is
how would that work for emergent
SpaceTime but I think that's not the
right question to ask because the point
is you're not starting with a wave
function that already is a function of
some concrete observable quantity you're
starting with a completely abstract ra
wave function what I mean by that is
think about the wave function as a
function of position okay s of X you
know that you could write that as a
function of momentum instead if you know
a little bit about quantum mechanics
that's a true fact again read my book
we'll talk all about it so s of X or S
of P these are two equivalent but
different looking ways to characterize
the same information the quantum state
of the system they're not two separate
wave functions they're the same wave
function written in different ways
they're the same underlying Quantum
state so what matters is that underlying
Quantum State not how you represented it
representing things in different ways is
just the choice of basis right it's a
choice of coordinates it's not something
that is physically relevant so
mathematically that wave function that
Quantum state is a vector in Hilbert
space and then you can sort of after the
fact find out that it is convenient to
represent that Vector as a function of
position or something like that in the
picture that we have of emergent
SpaceTime the vector is not a function
of anything it's not even easily
represented as a function of anything
it's just a vector it's just a Quantum
State it's an element of Hilbert space
and then there is a set of things you
got to do there is homework for you as
the working physicist to say okay how
can we represent this as something that
looks like something we would recognize
say space and the answer is you have to
sort of factorize it you have to divide
it up into subsystems and the subsystems
all look like the set of quantum degrees
of freedom associated with a point in
SpaceTime okay or a point in space I
guess it then evolves over time so the
you know the cheap and easy answer is
it's kind of like a lattice and it's
kind of like a set of points in space
and you have degrees of freedom at every
point and that's what the wave function
looks like but that's not exactly true
it's not a for one a pregiven lattice
you have to sort of figure out what kind
of lattice you have and number two it's
not even really a lattice the Lattis
doesn't even persist When Gravity
becomes important right when gravity
becomes strong like in a black hole or
ads CFT something like that when
holography kicks in then it's doesn't
look like a lattice at all so you just
have to trust the quantum State you just
have to accept that that's what it is
you have to give up on your uh training
which is to wrestle that quantum State
into some form that depends on something
else because that thing it depends on
position momentum etc those are relics
of your classical intuition those are
not things that are really fundamental
in this
picture Edward sackinger says to prove
nur's theorem which relates symmetries
to conserved quantities we assume that
the equations of motion can be derived
from the principle of least action this
is great for classical mechanics but in
quantum mechanics the findan path
integral also includes contributions
from paths other than the one with least
action could you please comment on the
applicability of nther theorem to
quantum physics sure uh this is actually
you know a good issue and it's one that
in the book that I keep talking about I
kind of danced around because even
though I mentioned nther theorum in
volume one I never proved it you know I
had a proof that I did in the videos it
just seemed to me to be a little bit
unenlightening it's like it's more a
demonstration of the author's
cleverness than it is a useful
pedagogical exercise so I didn't not my
cleverness whoever first authored these
uh proofs of nther theorem so I I left
it out of the book because I don't think
you learned much from it other than yes
nther theorem is true and then in the
quantum version you just have to prove
it again it's a different theorem right
um sometimes depending on how careful
your Quantum field Theory Professor is
if you take Quantum field Theory or for
that matter quantum mechanics um you
will be carefully told well sometimes
you will not be told that the classical
version of neer's theorem doesn't
suffice you know as you say in the
question in quantum mechanics there are
paths that are not the minimum value of
the action that still contribute to the
final answer so why should we expect
something like nther theorem some
connection between symmetries and
conserved quantities to still be true
the answer is you got to prove it again
you you can prove once again that
there's an operator that gives you a
value for these conserved quantities and
that operator is conserved over time as
long as you are just uh evolving
according to the short Ander equation
but it's a proof that is sort of needs
to be done over again once you stop stop
doing classical physics and start doing
quantum
mechanics Mark says do you care how and
for how long you will be remembered and
if so or not
why uh no I do not care at all uh and I
don't mind if people do care like I I do
believe the following thing that as we
exist here and
now part of what makes us happy or sad
or gives life value is our image of the
future even though even if we insist
that we will all someday be dead and
there's no afterlife Etc it's still okay
to care about the future uh in
particular I do care about the future
long after I'm dead in terms of things
like the state of the planet and the
state of the human race those things I
care about a lot I don't particularly
care about how I will be remembered I
hope that the people who knew me
personally remember me fondly that would
be nice uh but those people are going to
die too right so before too long
there'll be no one left uh to remember
me I don't care about even right now
like being famous I which I wish I were
less famous than I am to be honest the
only reason why it's good for some small
number of people to know who I am and
recognize me is two reasons number one
uh it helps me sell books and podcasts
which uh brings me money and I like
money and then number two more
importantly I get a feeling that
hopefully I am improving these people's
lives by teaching them science or
telling them about uh cool things about
the nature of reality Etc I think that's
a worthwhile project to do and if I do
think it's a worthwhile project to do
it's better to do it to more people than
to less people right if I think it's
useful to teach people science then it's
even more useful to teach more people
science but I'd be very happy if I could
do that
anonymously if I could you know be you
know get enough money to fix my roof and
also reach a lot of people but no one
knew who my name was I'd be perfectly
happy with that like you know in science
in academ
you have to make an impact if you want
to get a job right if you want to you
know be employed you have to write
papers that people recognize and go oh
yes that person's papers are very good
but now I have a job so I'm good with
that right so there's various
instrumental reasons why it's important
um that people know your name depending
on what your goals are but to me those
reasons are not intrinsic to having
people know my name I I get no special
um happiness out of uh people you know
more than five people people knowing my
name that's not something and when I'm
when I'm gone certainly not oh my
goodness no I have no interest
whatsoever
Personally Travis Martin says what is
science that's a good question what is
science you know I I think you have to
be cautious when you ask a question like
this because you're not going to get a
once and for all final answer this is a
whole research program people devote
their lives into figuring out what is
science there's famously the demarcation
problem between science and
non-science um falsifiability put
forward by Carl poer purports to be an
answer to the demarcation problem it's
not taken seriously by most working
philosophers but it that's what it's
aiming at doing separating science from
non-science when people try to argue
against uh whatever intelligent design
or crackpot theories or you know global
warming denial they will often try to
argue against those bad ideas by saying
well they're not really science and
they'll invent some definition of
science which tries to exclude them I
think this is kind of
mixing trying to understand the world
with trying to make the world a better
place right you know there is such a
thing as science that is bad so I have
no trouble calling intelligent designed
science it's just bad science it's
hilariously wrong science that doesn't
there are ways to argue against it
without saying that it's not science
okay with all that is preliminary and
therefore a promise that we're not going
to get the once and for all crisp clean
answer here I think science is an
attempt to understand how the world
works in the very very broad sense based
on a back and forth between hypotheses
and data between ideas about how the
world works and input
from experiment and observation on how
it actually does work um that's a very
subtle kind of thing so I don't include
math in science because math you don't
need any data to to do math right um
that's a it's related math is very
closely related to science it is
intrinsically important to doing science
but it is not itself science um you have
to be careful about what you mean by
getting the data because people will say
well wait a minute you believe in the
many world's interpretation of quantum
mechanics yes I believe in the many
world's interpretation of quantum
mechanics because that is a prediction
of the schinger equation which was
derived based on trying to fit the data
so you have to understand the take
aspects here it's not just a one-way
Street you get data you you invent the
simplest theory that explains it and
you're done it's a constant back and
forth between improving your ideas
improving your sensory inputs and trying
to make things better um and and
furthermore there are questions we have
scientifically to which the data don't
tell us the answer you know if if you
believe that there is dark matter you
don't know whether the dark matter is
weakly interacting massive particles or
axons or something else and nevertheless
you have opinions about what is more
likely and you should have opinions
because you need to spend money and you
need to spend your research time as we
were just talking about you need to
decide what is worth working on right so
you need to have opinions about that
where do those opinions come from where
does that Credence come from on Axion
versus weekly interacting massive
particles this is part of science
absolutely but it's not very algorithmic
it's not very clear it's not quite as
crisp and um systematized as people
might want it to be so science can be a
little bit messy
sometimes Craig Stevens says scientists
at Cornell University recently announced
the highest resolution photo of an atom
ever taken given that atoms are not
really particles but instead probability
distributions of waves what exactly are
they taking a photo of and what do they
hope to see so I'm not going to answer
this explicitly because I have no idea
what they did I do not know what this
photo is but I will point out that
people sometimes when they claim seem to
be taking a photo of a wave function in
some sense they cheat because you can't
take photos of wave function not in the
sense that you can take a photo of a
human being what you could do again I
have no idea with whether this is what
they did or not what you could do is you
could
sample a certain kind of wave function
over and over again to build up
statistically a picture of what it looks
like right you know that because it's
quantum mechanics if you take a just an
ordinary image of where the electron is
in an atom you don't see its wave
function you see it at a point you could
try to be more clever and have your
observable not exactly be the position
of the electron Etc but one way or the
other when you make an observation in
quantum mechanics you do disturb the
system if you're doing something that is
just an atom which is very reproducible
right you know you put the electrons in
their lowest energy states and they're
going to be in exactly the same state in
every version of that atom then you can
just do it again and again and build up
what the wave function must have been to
give you that observational probability
distribution maybe they did something
like that I just don't
know Michael monop says does the
collapse of the wave function affect the
gravitational field of the particle that
is all of a sudden in a particular
location uh yeah yeah it's supposed to
that's right although I have to hesitate
a little bit because even people who
believe in certain versions of the
foundations of quantum mechanics whether
it's many worlds or anything else don't
necessarily agree on every detail so in
particular in many worlds people don't
necessarily agree on should you imagine
that the world branches simultaneously
all at once in some reference frame
versus branching inside of a light cone
or something like that but having put
that caveat aside basically yes the wave
function collapse affects the
gravitational field everywhere note that
this is not a big deal because
you don't get a big gravitational field
unless you have a lot of mass right like
a single electron's gravitational field
is more or less completely ignorable and
once you have a lot of mass you have a
macroscopic system that is basically
being monitored by its environment all
the time so in practice in the real
world you don't get gravitational fields
suddenly shifting all throughout the
Universe because of quantum measurement
and wave function collapse they've
already been localized and they stay
localized for realistic
situations Johan Faulk says I have for
some time been trying to understand why
AI experts make radically different
assessments concerning AI risks I get
that people who don't know a lot about
AI have different conclusions but I
thought experts would agree more or at
least not disagree wildly I have two
main hypotheses and would love to hear
your thoughts one being an expert in AI
technology does not automatically make
you an expert in AI risks and two people
have different predispositions when it
comes to perceiving and reacting to to
low probability risks I think both of
these are true I mean especially number
one I think it's almost perfectly
obvious that being an expert in AI
technology does not automatically make
you an expert in AI risks nothing to do
with AI it's just a feature of
Technology the kind of skill set that
helps you develop a technology is just
not the kind of skill set that
automatically makes you an expert in the
risks of that technology all you have to
do is look at history and see all sorts
of unintended consequences coming from
new
Technologies maybe nobody is an expert
in these risks but certainly the fact
that you've built something doesn't mean
you know what it will do once you've
built it that's just a a feature of
these things and I think that there's
more to it than that also I mean there's
a certain kind of person who goes into
AI uh for certain predispositional
reasons and that might not line up well
with the best judgment when it comes to
what the risks are not that I have a
very good idea of what the RIS risks are
uh but I do agree well what you said is
that people who are experts in AI reach
different conclusions that's certainly
true people who are experts in AI um
absolutely do not have a consensus as to
what the risks are how big the risks are
how to deal with the risks anything like
that but I think in in addition to that
I'm kind of disappointed in the level of
discourse you know I think that um the
people who work on AI seem no less than
anyone else subject to over
anthropomorphizing the AIS I mean you
you heard about the guy at Google who
got fired because he was claiming that
chatbot was sentient right uh there are
philosophical issues here in what's
going on in Ai and how to interpret the
fact that they seem so lifelike in some
ways and yet can make pretty easy
mistakes um and I don't think that the
skill set that is sit required to sit
down and code and you know write a large
language model or deep Learning Network
or anything like that are the same as
the skills that lead you to really think
carefully about what the philosophical
implications are um you know physicists
were not great at coming up with the
implications of the atomic bomb even
though they helped build it right and
why would they be that's just not what
they're good at I don't know I'm halfway
contemplating do a doing a solo podcast
on AI and what I think about it um from
a semi-educated perspective not not I
don't know how to code and uh write up a
deep Learning Network but I've read a
lot and thought about a lot about Ai and
and the philosophical implications of it
so if that's worthwhile maybe that's
something I will do Aaron Berger says
I've heard that a scalar field is an
object with some value at every point in
space I've also heard that according to
some inflationary theories we could live
in a part of a cosmological Multiverse
in which there are numerous other CA L
separate universes if these two
propositions are true doesn't that imply
that every Universe in the cosmological
Multiverse would have the same set of
scalar Fields is another yes or no yes
and no question
because if well for one thing it depends
on a certain view of the laws of physics
uh a certain kind of semi-classical
quantum field Theory point of view even
in the presence of quantum gravity so
yeah but let's work with that that's
what most people do who are talking
about this that there are things called
scalar fields that we all agree on what
they are the the number of them is the
same Etc so the thing is that in
ordinary field Theory there is a way of
counting the number of degrees of
freedom basically a a way of counting
the number of different directions in
which Fields as a whole can vibrate okay
but how you classify those fields as
scalar or vector or whatever is not
invariant under different other external
circumstances so there are two important
things that change how you might go
about counting the number of scalar
Fields one is that a certain degree of
Freedom can show up under some
circumstances as a scaler some
circumstances as a vector or something
very different classic example is in the
good old standard model of particle
physics the original higs field has four
degrees of freedom it is what we call a
dublet there are two parts to the field
but it's a complex dublet so each part
is a complex number two real numbers so
four real numbers overall And yet when
you look at the large hyron collider you
detect a single real scalar field that
is the higs boson what happened to the
other three the answer is that they were
eaten by the w and z bosons a mass less
gauge Bon only has two degrees of
freedom a massive gauge Bon has three
and so what happens when the higs Bon
gets its expectation value three of the
degrees of freedom that were part of the
higs field now become part of the w and
z bosons so now they're not scaler
Fields anymore now they're part of the
vector Fields so you can't invariantly
count the number of scalar Fields the
other thing is the there's a sort of
question of how visible the fields are
if the fields are low mass then they
might typically be visible but if
they're very very high mass you just
can't make them they're kind of not
relevant to you even though they exist
in principle in the fundamental laws of
physics so at any energy scale where you
have access to fields at that energy
scale or below but not above you might
be missing some of the scalar Fields out
there so in practice it is not true that
there's the same number of scalar Fields
everywhere even principle there could be
deep down but that doesn't matter to a
single kind of Observer who has access
to certain things
Shan B says sorry if this is a naive
question but I've been pondering a
relationship between the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics in
the nature of Dark Matter given that
dark matter particles are massive yet
weakly interacting could they be related
to particles from separate branches of
the wave function in many worlds short
answer is no they cannot be and the
reason is because when you Branch when
you Deco here and split off different
parts of the universe the gravitational
field goes along with you so there is a
gravitational field that is responding
to the matter particles on your branch
and on a different branch there is a
different gravitational field responding
to a different set of particles the ones
on that Branch so there's no interaction
even through gravity between particles
on one branch and particles on another
Branch le e mcandrew says is it just a
philosophical question or a reality as
things line up within the judicial
legislative and maybe soon the executive
branches of our democracy sorry of our
government to destroy democracy there
appears to be such a headwind against
the rule of law and facts that it is
hard to see a clear way ahead well I
don't know if there's a headwind or not
um this is a question of course about
here in the United States where there
are increasingly people not only people
on the street but people in positions of
power uh whether or not it's the uh
executive or the Governors or the um
local school boards or the judges or
whatever who are more interested in
maintaining their power than in
being loyal to the principles of
democracy the thing about democracy is
it requires that the people in the
Democracy at least a majority of them be
willing to lose
elections uh you need to be willing to
fight for your beliefs and you know put
out the best case that you have and put
up good candidates but then if you lose
you concede that you have lost that is
the thing that is increasingly
disappearing and I don't think it's
equally spread between the various
parties I think it's pretty clear that
one party has this particular
perspective and it is fed it is fed I
think mostly from the outside right I
think that the people who are in
positions of power if the outside
pressures had been different would be
perfectly willing to go along with the
institutional Norms Etc but they're not
especially courageous people and when
the external factors whether it is
social media or Fox News or uh
conspiracy theorists with YouTube
channels or podcasts they buckled they
folded like a cheap suit and now they're
much more willing to just throw away the
principles of democracy such as
sometimes you can lose elections they're
much more willing to do everything they
can in their power to rig the rule R of
the actual voting so that it's
impossible for their party to lose even
if they're in the minority and I think
that's a problem I don't know how far it
will go I don't know if there's headwind
there uh it's certainly a recent change
but then there's a whole other party
that doesn't agree with that and there's
also still people within that party that
don't want to go along um the obvious
problem is when you have a somewhat
powerful group of people who don't
believe that they should ever be allowed
to lose elections one they actually get
into power they can rig things so that
they never do lose elections and that is
something we absolutely have to guard
against um I don't know what to say
other than it is clear that most
Americans are not motivated by a love of
democracy they might be motivated by a
love of their side on the Democracy but
and this is something that I think is
true on both sides so in terms of the
political parties and the establishment
there's a huge imbalance in terms of
which party is going to defend democracy
and which one is not I think that the
voters on either side very often would
be happy to get rid of democracy if they
think that they could install their side
as permanent Victors and that's too bad
I mean that's really a shame that's
something that I don't like I don't know
how to change it I mean clearly we have
not done a good job in this country in
inculcating a sense of civic
responsibility and an appreciation for
the benefits of democracy the thing
about democracy is even if you do lose
the system is going to be better for you
in the long term for most people so
there's a short-term gain long-term
benefit kind of thing uh Sor short-term
sacrifice long-term benefit kind of
thing people don't want to think that
way anymore and and that is a shame but
I have no constructive suggestions here
I'm not an expert on how to defend
democracy I'm in favor of doing it but
I'm also a empirical data driven kind of
guy and I don't know know what the
research says about how what is the best
way or even if there is any research the
best way to get people to really Buy in
to this kind of system of government
it's not easy to do and we kind of got
lucky for a couple hundred years in in
having it work as well as it did and now
we're running up against some obstacles
so I'm I'm worried and I don't have any
constructive
suggestions I'm going to group some
questions together here uh I anticipated
these questions a little bit one is
Benjamin barell says one thing I enjoy a
lot about your podcast is how your
teaching skills help me understand the
guest's arguments even when the subject
is quite subtle I must admit that you
somewhat failed me in the recent David
Deutsch episode several parts remain
quite obscure to me which is frustrating
because the topics felt very interesting
do you think you could reformulate his
point about the non-transitivity of
support that feminist Banker argument he
used stumped me despite careful Rel
listenings and John Hay says knock knock
who is there Linda Linda who would you
Lind us a hand by clarifying the Linda
example used by David deuts please so
I'm going to let you down on this
question for two reasons one is I don't
understand the Linda argument I don't
understand I tried I read uh the paper
by David and his collaborator uh against
basanis I am personally Pro basian so I
uh was resistant to whatever I was
trying to say I tried my best to open my
mind and figure out what was going on
you know you can prove theorems there's
a there's a theorem proven by poer and
Miller but then there's sort of okay
what are we supposed to get from that
theorem and I understand the theorem but
I just don't understand the leap to
denying basanis as a good way of doing
epistemology I think actually think
there are better arguments against
basanis even though I'm in favor of
basanis as David correctly disting
distinguished no one is arguing with
bases theorem that's a theorem okay but
the question is is the way to think
about how we gain knowledge sort of one
that is a natural fit to basis theorem
in the sense that you say what we do is
we have propositions and we attach
credences to all the propositions and we
update the prop the credences as new
data comes in if your objection to that
was something like nobody actually lists
all the propositions or nobody really
has credences for all the propositions
or people have credences but they're not
all internally consistent they don't all
add up to one for exclusive propositions
and things like that or when people get
new data they don't actually update
their credences using basis theorem all
of those I think are perfectly valid uh
objections to thinking of basian
epistemology as the way things work my
rough response to them is that I think
it's the way things should work not the
way things actually do work but I I take
the force of those objections that's not
David's objection you know he want to
say he wants to say that this idea that
we get new evidence and just update our
credences doesn't always correctly lead
us to what he would call the best
explanatory Theory um and somehow he
wants to connect it to this poer Miller
theorem by the the the point of that
theorem in his mind is to say that if
you think about new evidence that comes
in and you want to say okay my new
evidence supports a certain Theory right
supports a certain view of the world a
certain proposition what he wants to say
is you can divide the theory for which
you are looking for support into the
parts that are directly supported by the
evidence and the parts that are not
directly supported by the evidence and
then he wants to claim that the New
Evidence according to basian logic
increases the support for the part of
the theory that directly supports the
evidence but
decreases your Credence for the part of
the theory that is not directly
supported by the evidence that's what he
wants to say and I don't think that it
came clear it it came through clearly in
the Linda example so one problem is that
I don't understand what the argument is
but the other problem is he didn't say
it very well I know that in the podcast
uh you know he admitted that he he
misspoke at one point and he tried to
correct it I don't think the correction
was entirely um comprehensive uh I think
that that that example just kind of got
a little um garbled so I would recommend
if you're really interested in this
stuff reading David's papers or you know
his book uh the beginning of Infinity
for example and um just trying to get
into his mindset it's a very minority
point of view by the way um most most
not I don't know most people I don't
know how you count I don't know what the
measure is but some version of B
asianism seems to me to be like the
default epistemology among all sorts of
different people so that would be my
point of view Orin Harris asks a
priority question uh remember have we
not gotten a priority question yet this
time priority questions are once in your
lifetime you get to ask a question and I
will do my best to answer it I don't get
a chance to answer all the questions in
all the amas so Orin asks bore like
complimentarity in quantum mechanics and
the relativism of special and general
relativity are similar in their lack of
realism about Observer States EG viger's
friend versus relativity of simultaneity
or black hole complimentarity for
infalling versus external observers Etc
and for us realists Everett provides a
realist account of quantum mechanics
while I'm aware of no analogous realist
account of special or general relativity
complimentarity so if you are unhappy
with anti-realist accounts of quantum
mechanics why are you not similarly
unhappy with the current metaphysical
account of special relativity in general
relativity well I think that it's not so
simple as to say um a lack of realism
about Observer States in both cases in
general relativity uh in relativity
whether it's special or general and in
everying quantum mechanics they're
realist about certain things not realist
about others so in relativity you're
realist about SpaceTime you're not
realist about space or time individually
those are relative to observers likewise
in evering quantum mechanics you're
realist about the wave function the
quantum state of the universe you're not
really realist at a fundamental level
about branches of the wave function
those are observed by different
observers right that's why different
everan will have different schemes for
How the Universe branches and so forth
the branching is a emergent higher level
convenience to human beings so I think
in absolutely both cases it's the same
story that you have to be careful about
what it is is you are realist you can't
just say oh I'm a realist without saying
a realist about what and in both cases I
think it's clear what you should be
realist
about Ari Mai says my elderly mom 89
years old is a fundamentalist Christian
and convinced we are in the end times I
am an atheist who rejects all of this
she's at the phase of her life where
she's devastated that I'll be in Hell
For Eternity and tells me this all the
time I'm struggling how to deal with
this heavy weight on her heart any
advice every time we speak she begs me
to renounce by atheism and this is a
horrible way to live for both of us I
think that this question I mean it's a
tough question you know I I feel bad for
you being in this position um I don't
think it has a lot to do specifically
with atheism or religion or anything
else I think it has to do with you know
how you deal with people
who react emotionally to your cherished
beliefs right which what gives your your
care and your love for these other
people or your loyalty to your cherished
beliefs and I don't think there's a hard
and fast rule I think that it's going to
depend on the circumstances so one way
of saying it is I don't think that
there's any
moral um
obligation to be honest with your mom or
with anyone else about what your beliefs
are if you think it would make the world
a better place so this is a case in
other words where I am a
consequentialist not a deontologist so
if you think it would make your the
world a better place um to just tell
your mom that you know you're wavering
in your atheism or you're open to
religion or whatever then that's fine if
you want to do that but I also think
there are two people to consider here
there's your mom and there is you right
you both have some standing here and if
on the other hand you feel that not
being honest about your beliefs would be
a self- betrayal of some kind then I
don't think that you have any obligation
to tell your mom that you have renounced
your beliefs that if she is not going to
be reasonable about accepting your
beliefs then you know someone's going to
be unhappy and that's that's going to be
the way it is so therefore I don't think
that there's any from on high hard and
fast rule about how to deal with a
situation like this you have to try to
balance you have to try to weigh your
feelings against her
feelings would she even believe you if
you said that you were renc ing your
atheism uh would it make you miserable
for the rest of your life if you were to
do that you're in a bad position and I
and I do feel sorry for you about that
um she is the one who's being
unreasonable no question about that but
uh you know she's 89 years old and she's
elderly and you know you might want to
try to be considerate to her wishes you
know I when people are reaching age of
89 they're going to be a little
unreasonable I'm sure I'm going to be
totally unreasonable when I'm 89 I hope
people learn to put up with me a little
bit you your hard decision is how much
exactly you want to put up with her I
can't help you with that but I do wish
you luck Ken Schneider says what is the
significance of the fact that the
standard model can't be
quantized I do not know what you're
talking about Ken the standard model is
the quintessential quantum mechanical
Theory uh gravity can't be quantized all
the way gravity can be quantized fine if
it's just weak field gravity that's part
of the core Theory there's a perfectly
good quantum theory of gravity that
works here in the solar system as an
effective field Theory um but that's not
part of the standard model standard
model is just everything else and it is
quantized there's one other loophole
that is a little bit subtle the standard
model has in it of course a U1 gauge
Theory um which descends after symmetry
breaking to electromagnetism and that is
not perfectly 100% well defined there's
something called the landow pole which
is a singularity that that happens way
way above the plank scale where you
can't extend the rules of quantum
electrodynamics to infinitely High
energies Quantum chromodynamics you can
it works perfectly well you know non-ab
gauge theories with ASM totic Freedom
you can quantize but not uh Quantum
electrodynamics all the way but you can
still quantize it as an effective field
Theory below some cut off perfectly well
so I wouldn't worry about this standard
model is super duper quantized Rob gbla
says could there be a consistent theory
of gravity also allowing for
anti-gravity I.E the force being
repulsive instead of attractive for some
particles even it doesn't apply to our
real world and could that be compatible
with both relativity and quantum
mechanics at least in low energy EFT
regime well you know you can always
write down a theory which is exactly the
theory that we have a general relativity
plus various matter fields and just have
as a coupling constant you have Newton's
constant of gravity right so you can
just make that negative you could just
say I'm going to look at a world where G
Big G Newton's constant is negative and
then when you plug into the formula for
Newtonian gravity you would get a
repulsive Force but there's a problem
with that which is that that same
coupling constant G also in the action
in the you know the action being the
thing that we use to define the entire
Theory also tells you the kinetic energy
of
gravitons so if we're think of you know
specifically basically general
relativity we're not inventing a whole
new theory of gravity um we're thinking
just general relativity with a negative
Newton's constant then not only do you
make gravity repulsive by changing the
sign of Newton's constant but you make
gravitons have negative energy that's
just bad that's just not allowed because
a negative energy particle means that
empty space is unstable this is a point
that I made in my paper with Mark
trodden and Mark Hoffman years ago um
about Phantom energy you can't just make
the kinetic energy of particles negative
it leads to Wild instabilities of empty
space so um that would be bad is there
something more clever you can do that I
don't know actually I I thought about
this a little bit um but I don't know
I've tried you know you would like to
have something spatially dependent or
something like that so that gravity can
be repulsive in certain cases or it's
it's hard though and the basic reason is
card it always comes down to the same
basic reason that it's hard to make
gravity repulsive while keeping the
masses and energies of regular particles
all positive I don't know what to do
about that Ken wolf has said I've heard
the mechanism of Hawking radiation
described as a particle pair rising at
the Event Horizon where a particle of
negative Mass falls into the black hole
and a particle of positive Mass escapes
is this a valid way of looking at it and
if not why well it's kind of a valid way
of looking at it I mean it's fine you
know it's not the right correct final
answer the right correct Final Answer
involves solving for the vacuum state of
a Quantum field theory in a black hole
SpaceTime background right and
ultimately that's the right answer do
the equations okay um then you want to
attach words to those equations to
describe what's going on the closest
words you can come up with will have
things to do about Quantum fields and
vacuum modes and boundary conditions and
things like that
so that's not very intuitive you can use
all those words and you can get the
right answer and it would be correct but
not a lot of us come across those things
in our everyday lives so what you notice
in um general relativity just classical
general relativity is that you can
Define the energy of a particle as
observed from infinity and you can
attach a number to that and if a
particle is inside the black holes of
ENT eyes
that number the energy as observed from
Infinity can be negative okay this is a
classical general relativity statement
it is just correct if you define exactly
what you mean by energy the energy of a
particle inside the Event Horizon as
observed from Infinity can be a negative
number and when you look at the quantum
field Theory calculation that honking
does there's a flux of radiation out and
a flux of radiation in and the radiation
in has a negative um mass as observed
from Infinity that's why the black hole
shrinks so it is a little poetic and a
little bit of an exaggeration but
nevertheless does track more or less
what happens to say that a particle pair
at the Event Horizon splits apart and a
negative Mass particle goes in and a
positive Mass particle goes out as long
as you appreciate that this is a
somewhat poetic and colorful translation
of an underlying careful calculation you
should be
fine Bob zanelli says axons are a
leading cold Dark Matter candidate what
process can create such low mass
particles as cold Dark Matter one would
think they'd be highly relativistic like
neutrinos yeah this is a great question
this really confused me when I first
learned about axons so for those of you
who don't know when we talk about weakly
interacting massive particles as I said
before with my paper with um Kim body
Mark trodden about strongly interacting
Dark Matter there is a conventional
story that we tell that tells us The
Relic abundance of such particles and
that conventional story is called
thermal freeze out at very high
temperatures in the very very early
Universe all the particles were bumping
into each other and they had some
thermal distribution and they would both
annihilate when they hit another
antiparticle but also be created when a
particle uh decayed into them or two
particles scattered and created them so
they are in some sort of equilibrium
state but then the temperature is of
course changing because the universe is
expanding and cooling off and at some
point which you can calculate you reach
a point where the particles just don't
Collide anymore they just don't
annihilate anymore because the universe
is the the temperature is too low and
the density is too low so the
probability of any one particle bumping
into an anti-particle and annihilating
just is effectively zero and that is
called freeze out it's very sensitive to
things like the mass and the um
cross-section for annihilation of the
particle um but you can do it you can
calculate The Relic abundance of these
particles and what you want to get what
you what you get for a good Dark Matter
candidate is a relatively heavy particle
with a weak interaction cross-section
that gives you the right Relic abundance
now axons are super light particles um
the mass of an Axion you know in the
most popular models we've not detected
the Axion yet we don't even know if it
exists so I shouldn't act like it exists
but in the most popular models for Axion
dark matter they Mass masses are very
low in fact the mass of the Axion is
comparable to maybe a little bit less
than the energy of a typical Photon in
the cosmic microwave background what
that means is in the early Universe if
the axons were in thermal equilibrium
then they'd be moving at the speed of
light their energies would be much much
higher than their Mass which move which
means they're moving very close to the
speed of light and even today they'd be
close to the speed of light of order the
speed of light they wouldn't have slowed
down very much therefore if they're
particles moving close to the speed of
light they are not cold dark matter they
are super hot Dark Matter so what's
going on how can axons be a leading cold
Dark Matter candidate the answer is they
were never in thermal
equilibrium even though the universe was
a hot dense state in order to be in
thermal equilibrium particles have to be
able to interact with the surrounding
plasma well enough to equilibrate you
know if you have two objects that are at
different temperatures and you put them
into cont contact with each other they
equilibrate and they come to the same
temperature that's true even if your
quote unquote objects are two different
species of gas in the same container but
if you don't put them together if they
don't interact with each other then the
two things are not going to come to the
same temperature so axons interact very
very weakly so they do not equilibrate
with the rest of the universe and the
way that they're produced is just
entirely different it is not freeze out
from an initial high temperature State
uh there's a whole story I'm not going
to tell it here but there's a whole
story about how axons arise from
spontaneous symmetry breaking and then
there is a moment typically the qcd
phase transition when the Axion starts
oscillating back and forth as a very low
mass um zero temperature Bose Einstein
condensate of particles uh but you can
still do the same kind of calculation
it's not sorry not the same kind of
calculation you can still do a
calculation that tells you what the
Relic abundance is and that's why we
have
opinions about things like what the mass
of the Axion should be because we know
that the Relic abundance at the end of
the day depends on the mass of the Axion
and we know what we need the Relic
abundance of dark matter to be all of
this still speculative of course but it
does hang together very nicely so the
short answer is the axons were never in
thermal equilibrium they were created in
a completely different mechanism Adam
rot Mill says if the theory of
eternalism holds up where moments in the
past present and future are all equally
real then what happens to our sense of
identity like are those parts of
ourselves still conscious in their local
time coordinates I suppose Hume called
this the notion of resemblance that we
continue to resemble ourselves even
though we keep changing but you've said
in the past that different branching
copies of ourselves are different people
so where should we draw the line on
identity and why well I think that the
whole idea of identity in my view of the
world is a higher level emergent
phenomenon so it's going to be impris
precise right just like tables and
chairs are imprecise at what point do
you stop calling a table a table if you
remove it Atom from Atom atam from atam
from the table um likewise in a world
where people are changing what exists
you know what really exists forget about
quantum mechanics and many worlds and
stuff like that you have atoms and
molecules with World lines persisting
over time but you know that a human
being is not the same collection of
atoms over time so it's not that this
particular collection of atoms is your
personal identity it's some kind of
pattern that is formed by the atoms that
gives you memory and personality and
physical continuity Through Time Etc so
I think that's the right way to think
about it and that's going to be I'm not
quite sure what eternalism has to do
with it honestly um whether you're a
presentist and think that there's some
continuity between your present self and
your past self but only the present self
really exists or you're an eternalist
and you think that they both have an
existence the story is the same as far
as I can tell I would just warn you
against saying things like those parts
of ourselves are still conscious because
I know you put so you don't you folks
listening to this don't know but Adam
put the word still in quotes don't even
put them in
quotes in the moment when some previous
version of you exists that version of
you exists right and that moment of
existence has just as much reality as
the current moment of existence but it
doesn't exist at the same time or
simultaneously or still they both just
are real any more than this location in
space exists at the same location as
some other location in space even though
they both exist and are real just think
of it that
way Chris Rogers says beyond the aventor
Horizon does a black hole have a surface
if not why not cuz I don't understand
well I think you to be a little bit more
specific about what it is you don't
understand Chris um a black hole is a
region of SpaceTime a region where
anything that goes in can't come out
without moving faster than the speed of
light that's the definition of a black
hole it's not an object it's a region in
many ways it acts like an object so we
know why you might think that it is
object like uh it has a mass you can
move it around it radiates and things
like that but what it really is is a
region of SpaceTime so no there's no
surface Beneath The Event Horizon there
is a singularity but as I've often
remarked The Singularity is in the
future not in some location in space so
the singularity is something to which
you will evolve once you're inside the
black hole not a surface you could
imagine standing
on valorian asks a priority question
what do you think of my new past Eternal
cosmological model and there's a link to
a Wikipedia page in it all ancient Koshi
surfaces of the default kind are as nice
as the bounce surface in your Carol Chen
model and there is no reversal of the
arrow of time uh I don't have any
thoughts about it because I don't know I
don't know about it sorry I don't know
anything about it so I can't really say
anything I think by the way I will say
parenthetically that the reversal of the
arrow of time is not only allowed but
actually good I think that the idea that
the arrow of time points in different
directions in the far past and the far
future is actually very nice it add a
symmetry restores a symmetry to the
overall cosmological history that we
believe the underlying laws of physics
have so I think that's a good thing so
getting rid of that I don't think to see
C is any particular kind of
virtue Adam small says I was having a
conversation here with the community
about emerence and it appears from a
whole bunch of basic units of let me see
sorry and that it appears from a whole
bunch of basic units from whatever
macroscopic thing you're talking about
so then I said do a thought experiment
and remove one of the particles or units
at a time until you don't get emergent
Behavior one of the smart members said
that's called the sores Paradox just
wondering how you think about that and
what it means it seems to really mess up
the concept of emergence Since By
definition it can't depend on a single
particle or unit of the whole I don't
think this is a paradox the S Paradox is
a well-known thing it's just a
reflection of the fact that as we just
said higher level emerging phenomena are
approximations that are going to be
valid in certain circumstances and not
and the thing about approximations is
they don't stop instantly being valid at
any one point they just become worse and
worse it's like saying how tall do you
have does a person have to be to be tall
rather than short different people are
going to disagree on the exact number
the exact number of centimeters or
inches and feet that you have to be tall
that doesn't mean that the concept of
being tall is useless right it conveys
information it's not precise it's
approximate information it might be
slightly different information for
different people and yet it is still
useful so ideas like tables and chairs
are much more well- defined than that
but they share this property that
they're not precisely defined it's not a
boundary for those of you don't know the
sorties Paradox is anyway my my way of
thinking of it you know you have
something like a table you agree it's a
table now you remove an atom is it still
a table yes remove another atom still a
table yes but if you keep removing atoms
eventually you'll get down to just one
atom when is clearly not a table so at
what point do you cross the threshold
from being a table to not being a table
that's a silly question it just becomes
less and less table like there's no
threshold for you to cross Elliot spec
says I enjoyed your podcast with Mari
ruti in which you discussed laon's
version of psychoanalysis the analysis
is based on Universal Origins for Human
anst posited by Lon you asked ruy
whether this theory was scientific I.E
verifiable and she conceded that it was
not she described it as
mythology this an is just half the
question there are certainly useful ways
of thinking that are not scientific my
question should critics such as you
demand that scientific techniques be
used to determine whether Leon's
analysis really is useful anecdotal
accounts seem like a weak basis for
choosing a medical treatment well
there's a lot going on here I actually
have a quite expansive definition of
what is scientific as I said I have no
trouble thinking of lonian
psychoanalysis as scientific I think of
it as very similar to traditional
Chinese medicine for example I can
absolutely imagine that there are cures
or um di uh not diagnosis but
prescriptions from ancient traditional
medicines whether Chinese or anywhere
else that help you that help you get
better and I could even imagine doing a
test you know doing a double blind
experiment that shows they help you get
better and I can imagine that all this
happens without us understanding why it
helps you get better right I don't know
I actually have no strong opinions about
whether or not acupuncture actually
helps my understanding is that no one
understands why acupuncture should help
to me that's no barrier to it helping I
think there's a separate question if it
does help then that should be testable
right that the fact that it helps should
be uh verifiable um but again the
verification is kind of not on or off
it's not yes or no you build your way up
to it uh if there is any psychological
theory psychological theory not just
psychoanalytic it might be very
difficult to test it but whether or not
it helps people at the at the level of
therapy that's an empirical question
that you can just go out and test so
whether or not the you understand why it
helps is is kind of irrelevant so I may
or may not be convinced by the uh
specificities of one or someone else's
psychoanalytic or psychological theory
but I'm pretty Loosey Goosey when it
comes to asking that it be verified I
don't I don't think you need you know to
collect rigorous quantitative data or
have a me me mechanistic understanding
of What Lies Beneath I just want it to
work and work means something that is
actually verifiable or demonstrable
using empirical
testing Tim Converse says great to hear
your about your collaboration with Scott
Aronson I understand from Aronson's
popularizations that there are hard
physics-based limits on how much
computation you can do in a region of
space my question is if some
civilization were trying to max out
their computational resources and
driving right up to physical limits
might there be observational signatures
that would indicate that was happening
something analogous to observing Dyson
spheres but for computation rather than
for
energy uh my I haven't thought about
this very carefully but my short guess
is no uh I'll tell you why because if
you really think about maxing out your
computational
resources there are ways to do
computations that are what we call
reversible okay they do not actually
generate entropy but most computations
and in fact the interesting ones the
ones where we involve not just
calculating something but then reading
out the outcome of the calculation you
know putting into memory things like
that those do uh require entropy
increase and therefore heat and
therefore radiation and I'm I'm betting
without having thought about it very
carefully that the most efficient way to
do this would be to just have the
radiation you're giving out be black
body radiation at a certain temperature
so at the end of the day even though
you're doing something very Advanced and
fancy and technologically sophisticated
what you're admitting out to the
universe is black body radiation and
that comes from a lot of places Dyson
spheres but maybe other things as well
so I don't think it would be an
especially unique or um noticeable
signature out there in space again I
haven't thought about this in any detail
so it could be wrong about that Casey
Mahone says if I'm doing the math
correctly you met your wife relatively
late in your life did you ever feel
hopeless about finding love I don't know
if you're familiar with the current
dating climate at all but the world of
dating apps seems like a complete waste
of time and it feels challenging to meet
other people once you are out of school
any words of
wisdom yeah you know uh no I did not
ever feel hopeless about finding love
but I felt um perfectly content with the
idea of remaining single for my whole
life I think I thought I was having a
good time um I I always thought that it
would be better to be in love with
somebody and have a partner and things
like that but I wasn't despondent nor
did I rely on that for my own personal
happiness is so I was doing fine I think
um one thing I was always devoted to was
not rushing into getting married or a
long-term committed relationship just
for the sake of having a marriage or a
committed relationship I wanted it only
to happen if I was with a person who I
knew that it's the person I wanted to be
with not the institution of marriage or
commitment Etc so I was comfortable
being relatively old and still being
single I am not that familiar with the
current dating climate um and I
absolutely acknowledge that the dating
climate is something that changes over
time so what it is like now might be
radically different than what it was 10
or 20 years ago much less when I was in
high school or college or something like
that so I feel for you I feel that it is
difficult especially as you say once
you're out of school college and even
graduate school is you know an easy
place to meet people you're still pretty
young when you're in college so it might
not be the best place to meet people
people who are exactly right for you the
one thing I will say you know I'm all in
favor in principle of dating apps and
and things like that that is a way to
meet people there's obviously an a a one
huge advantage of them and one huge flaw
and you should be aware of both the huge
Advantage is by construction the two
people who meet already agree that
they're looking to be in a relationship
or at least looking to date right
they're not it's not like you're going
to go on a dating M app meet somebody
set up an arrangement and then come to
meet them and they say oh no you know
I'm already in a committed relationship
with somebody else at least not unless
they're just yanking your chain or
something like that so that's a huge
head up like if you meet someone at work
or in a social situation you might not
know whether they are looking or
committed or whatever so huge benefit to
the dating apps that way there's also a
huge disadvantage I which I think is not
given a lot of attention which is that
we human beings are not that good at
knowing what it is we want especially
when it comes to looking for possible
romantic Partners we tend to think in
terms of a list right there's a
checklist I want someone with this and
this and this and that's never right you
know the things that make two people
compatible with each other are very
rarely reducible to items in a list or
if they are you only discover them after
you meet the person and go oh that's
what I needed all along right you need
some kind of personal compatibility with
a person uh I've noticed when we for
example accept new graduate students
into a physics department I've often
notice that we put a lot of work into
accepting the right students right and
we look at their file and their you know
scores and their grades and their
letters of recommendation and their
personal statement and whatever and then
I meet them and in both directions both
like oh my goodness we've let this
person in and we shouldn't or oh my
goodness we didn't let this person in
and we should 10 minutes of talking to a
person about physics is more informative
than their entire file no matter how
carefully you look at it and I think
something very similar happens with
dating people there is such a thing as a
personal connection there are things you
have to be open to the fact that you or
the possibility anyway that you cannot
articulate what it is you're looking for
that's not bad that's not you know a
terrible flaw it would be nice maybe if
you could articulate it but you have to
be open to the fact that you don't know
you have to be open to the fact that
you're meeting people getting to know
them and changing your mind about what
it is you were looking for and I think
that dating apps really sort
of pretend that this list based way of
finding human beings is the right way to
do it you know and the lists might be
you know it doesn't need to be like oh
you have certain height certain income
or anything like that even just a list
of your interests I'm looking for people
with similar interests well are you
really is that really the most important
thing maybe you will find somebody who
has very different interests but
nevertheless you're compatible being
with them and you can begin to share
their interests so I think that dating
apps have not at the current um state of
Technology really given us a window into
what it is that people actually require
in terms of making a connection and
moving forward so the only thing to do
about that is keep trying you know uh
the nice thing like I said about dating
apps is at least you know everyone on
them is trying to date so go through
them very quickly once you're older by
the way everyone realized every most
people recognized this phenomenon when
you were young and you started to read a
book you felt you had to finish it you
started it later on in life you're like
nah this book isn't isn't working out
for me after two chapters I'm putting it
down think likewise about people save
yourself some time you know if you know
someone is not working
out go to on to somebody else right like
if you're already in love and invested
in whatever then try to work it out but
early on I think it's okay to to move
quickly Dan Berliner says you mentioned
in an earlier AMA that one of the ways
gravity is special is that it interacts
with everything does this mean gravitons
would interact with themselves and if so
would they not experience confinement in
the same way as gluons so yes gravitons
do interact with themselves and in some
sense again you know these are stories
that we tell this is not the math
underlying the stories but in some sense
it's that interaction of gravity with
itself that makes general relativity a
little bit different than Newtonian
gravity that gives rise to the
difference in the procession of the
orbit of mercury in Einstein versus
Newton but that doesn't mean that they
have to be confined that depends not on
whether there are interactions but
whether the interactions are strong or
weak and really when you get into it it
depends on how the strength of the
interactions changes with energy the
thing about the strong nuclear force is
not only that its interactions are
strong but that they get stronger as the
energy gets lower okay as you go to
lower and lower energies which is longer
and longer distances in Quantum field
theory of particle physics the strength
of the interaction goes up so when you
try to pull two quarks together the
force pulling them toward each other uh
the energy in that Force grows enough
that eventually you just make a quark
anti- Quark pair and you've not actually
separated the quarks just like when you
pull apart the ends of a piece of string
if it breaks in the middle you don't
have two unaccompanied ends you just
have two pieces of string with two ends
each so that's a feature that you need
to get confinement and that feature does
not exist in gravity gravitons interact
with each other but only very weakly and
unnoticeably when the gra when the
energy becomes very low in fact guess
what photons do the same thing photons
interact with each other they don't
interact with with each other directly
directly but there are such a thing as
virtual particles and two photons can
interact by exchanging virtual electrons
and protons uh and positrons sorry so or
for that matter by exchanging virtual
protons and antiprotons but that's a
much tinier effect at low energies below
the mass of the electron where you don't
see real electrons it is as if photons
are just interacting with each other but
again their interactions are so weak you
would never notice it's a the itical
calculation you can do it's not
something that is very relevant to the
actual behavior of electromagnetic
fields in the macroscopic
world Mike mcmanis says is super
symmetry Dead uh nope it is not dead its
Credence has gone down since the days of
uh even just 20 years ago 20 years ago
there was still a lot of room both for
discovering new super symmetric
particles at the large hedron collider
and discovering part particles in Dark
Matter detectors that would be
eventually explicable in terms of super
symmetry neither one of those things has
happened so by any rational accounting
whatever Credence you used to put on
Super symmetry you should put less now
because you could have discovered it
there and you didn't but it's certainly
not dead it's absolutely possible that
super symmetry is a real part of the
world it just is broken at very very
high energies and has nothing to do with
our low energy world to many working
particle physicist that's a shame if
that turns out to be true because low
energy super symmetry was really useful
it helps explain the hierarchy problem
which is the difference in Mass between
the higs boson and the plank scale it
maybe helps explain what the dark matter
is it was just good for all sorts of
reasons plus it gave full employment to
particle physicists building
accelerators but the idea of super
symmetry is much more Broad and robust
than just this specific sub idea of low
energy super symmetry low even low
energy super symmetry is not dead but
it's on life support I would I would put
it that way uh we could have found it
very very easily and we haven't so you
have to stretch your imagination a
little bit to imagine that it's there
but high energy super symmetry is still
100%
alive Jeff B says I'm trying to wrap my
head around emerg in SpaceTime I think I
understand that you are defining the
wave function to exist in a more
abstract space of degrees of freedom and
these degrees of freedom happen to be
connected in such a way that they
produce the appearance of SpaceTime
Dimensions my question is
if the degrees of freedom are so
perfectly coordinated that they mimic
SpaceTime geometry wouldn't it be more
logical to Simply assert that there is
something called SpaceTime which ties
these degrees of freedom together I
maybe could have grouped this question
with the previous one about emerging
SpaceTime but the answer is no it is not
more logical to Simply assert there's
something called space time that ties
these degrees of freedom together
because the thing about emergence this
seems to be a theme of today's AMA it's
in it's a higher level approximation it
is not the fundamental thing so if
SpaceTime emerges from some more
fundamental sets of degrees of freedom
it will very likely plausibly do so in
some regimes but not in others so it's
crucially important that you have some
degrees of freedom and they are only
emerging into SpaceTime rather than in
some sense being SpaceTime from the
start because it gives you more
flexibility and the evidence is that
that flexibility is going to be useful
because our notion of SpaceTime seems to
be different when it comes to situations
where holography is important like in a
black hole or in a cosmology or probably
at the Big Bang in places like that so
it really does matter which is the more
fundamental thing which is the emerging
thing Valor up says if space flight in
the near future becomes commercially
feasible would you participate would you
visit a space hotel or a hotel on the
moon what sort of fun and interesting
attractions could you see being
presented you know in principle I would
but but there's a Race Against Time here
and I'm losing this Race Against Time uh
I don't think that feasible space hotels
or hotels on the moon are coming very
very soon I don't by very very soon I
mean two decades from now right so I'm
going to be in my 70s uh two decades
from now and I don't think that flying
in a spaceship to the moon and hanging
out there will be the best for my
long-term life expectancy um I think you
know it's okay it's fine again I'm was
never my motivation since I was a kid
was never like to go to space I like
reading stories about it I like reading
about astrophysics and cosmology but my
interest is in how the world works not
in visiting outer space so if there's a
finite number of slots on the spacecraft
that would go to the moon or whatever
there are people out there who would get
more out of it then I would and I'll be
a little bit over the hill by the time
that time happens so you know in
different circumstances where I was
super healthy and I was absolutely
convinced that the travel was completely
safe then I would be 100% in favor of it
I would love to do it it sounds like fun
sounds like a little Adventure right I
like going Adventures you know like
going to different countries here on
Earth so of course I would like an
adventure that would go into space but
again I I'm not really convinced that it
will be safe I think that it will happen
before it becomes safe right it's easy
to imagine you know especially if
private companies can do it and make
money out of it we know from how private
companies work that they're more
interested in making money than making
things completely safe and it might be
90% safe but 10% not safe is a huge
amount of not safe space travel is
dangerous it just is and maybe someday
it won't be but our current version very
much is so I'm happy to enjoy my life
here on Earth too many good things I got
to do to risk it all for one little trip
to the
moon hil's Zeus says I really enjoyed
something deeply hidden and I have a
question that I don't think you
explicitly addressed in your book when
solving for the time of flight of a
thrown ball we get one positive and one
negative answer and we discard the
negative answer is non-physical which no
one loses sleepover there are numerous
other examples in physics of Simply
throwing out wrong answers by analogy
then what is the issue with throwing out
some of the answers to the schinger
equation I think I understand the logic
of if the shortener equation is perfect
and all-encompassing then many worlds
but the if statement here seems to be
carrying an awful lot of water yeah this
is a very insightful question I think
but the situations are not as analgous
as you are making them out to be when it
comes to forget about SpaceTime and and
the time of travel think about
Pythagoras's Theorem right the
hypotenuse C of a right angle of right
triangle compared to its shorter sides A
and B satisfies a^2 + b s = c^2 so
straightforwardly looking at that
equation you say well A and B could be
positive but C could be negative and I
could solve that equation with a
negative distance between the two points
so what like you're missing the point
the distance is just something that is
defined to be positive it happens to
obey that equation but it's positive
even though we we know it's positive
even though there is a negative solution
to the equation that's a little bit
different than a situation like the dur
equation where there are different
solutions which we now know represent
positrons and as well as electrons right
that was an extra solution which it
would have been a mistake to throw away
people thought about throwing it away
because they didn't know the positrons
existed but that would have been a
mistake the schinger equation is
actually a much simpler example because
there aren't extra Solutions the
schinger equation is linear it is not s
squar equals something so you can find s
or minus s it's just s equals something
you can figure out thus solution and
then you got to accept the solution or
not so you can change the Schrodinger
equation people try to do that those are
the objective collapse models but if you
don't change the shortener equation you
get the multiple worlds that's all there
is to it it's not a matter of getting
extra solutions that you're throwing out
the solution includes multiple worlds
that's a different
situation only normal person says could
you elaborate on how moral
constructivism gets through the ought
from is problem it seems like an
accurate way to describe constructivism
would be it is true that almost all
humans have moral inclinations even if
specific intuitions are not Universal so
we ought to work to make our
inclinations as coherent and consistent
as possible that certainly works for me
intuitively but I feel like I must be
missing a piece of formal logic based on
your other statements yeah I would argue
that yes you are missing a piece of
formal logic here I never say we ought
to make our inclinations as coherent as
consistent as possible I have goals and
desires so to me it's not that ought
doesn't exist ought can exist it can't
be derived from is if I say a certain
thing ought to be the case or ought to
happen I cannot do an experiment to show
that I'm wrong as I would be able to do
if I were making a scientific statement
about the behavior of the world that
doesn't mean that I can't talk the
language of aarts I can say you know you
want to do this but what it means is
something different what it means is
within this framework that I personally
subjectively individually have come to
accept based on my human intuitions and
inclinations and and whatever the
history of myself as an individual and
descendant of a species Etc I've come up
with these ideas about what ought to be
the case and what not ought to be the
case and I can tell you what they are
what that doesn't mean is that I've
derived what ought to be true from what
is true in the world I'm just
expressing how I feel and I don't think
that I think that the the problem in
deriving ought from is so let's put it
this
way to me the closest that you can come
to arguing that you should be able to
derive on from is is to say look is is
all there
is by as by being a naturalist by being
a physicalist you're saying that all
that exists is the physical world right
so everything that is true true should
follow from what is true in the world
including the a statements that sounds
almost you know convincing there and the
mistake in it is to think that all
statements are true things that are
derivable that's the problem so they're
not they're a different kind of thing
they're judgments judgments are not true
false statements that're derivable in
the same way that empirical statements
or mathematical statements or whatever
are so I think it all fits together just
admitting that you cannot derive OD from
is
laurant deer says I enjoyed watching the
YouTube replay of your debate on is
consciousness fundamental with Philip
goof on September 8th your humor makes
dry subject so much easier to understand
I may be biased but I feel like Philip's
way to convince people that he is right
is by being super passionate at exposing
strange arguments my question to you is
why do you think he never answers you
when you ask whether he wants to change
the core Theory or not change it it's a
simple enough question did he answer
that elsewhere
um no he doesn't answer that I think
he's actually pretty explicit that he
doesn't answer that and that's fine he's
honest that he doesn't answer it he he
says that maybe the core Theory will
have to be changed maybe it won't his
attitude is that Consciousness comes
first that the core Theory may or may
not have to adapt to it he doesn't know
but what he knows is how Consciousness
works I just don't think this is a
sensible attitude for a pans psychist to
have because I think that we understand
well it's not just I think it it's
obviously true that we understand the
core Theory enormously better and we
have enormously more empirical support
for it than any statement we can make
about Consciousness other than that it
exists any specific statement about what
Consciousness is how it works anything
like that these are much much harder
claims to make than anything about the
core Theory so I think that it just
makes sense
intellectually that if you have
something that is extremely well
established and something else that is
not really well understood then you'd
better be clear about what you're doing
with the well-established piece before
you draw conclusions based on your
intuitions or thought experiments about
the not very well understood piece so I
disagree with Philip's stance but at
least he's clear on what his stance
is goant says there's a set of
philosophers scientists out there who
believe that Free Will is an illusion
spolski comes to mind is that champion
of this view what I've never heard them
explain what I've never heard them
explain is the Hitler problem as I call
it relative to the non-existence of free
will that is doesn't the lack of free
will give Hitler a
pass so I get the argument I think I
think what you're getting at is the is
the following idea that when we talk
about morality or we talk about ethics
or we talk
about judgment more generally right this
is good this is bad this is right this
is wrong it does seem to rest on the
possibility that things could have been
different right if you say well you did
the wrong thing and I say well I didn't
have any choice but to do it like if
someone throws me out the window and I
land on another person and injure their
back you know in in general injuring
someone else's back is the wrong thing
to do but here I had no choice I was
thrown out the window the law of gravity
took over I'm kind of blameless for that
right and if you take a very strong
opinion about free will that it just
doesn't exist you never have any choices
there are no choices then there
absolutely is an argument that no one is
to be blamed for anything right now I I
think that some anti-free will people
kind of just avoid this right kind of
don't face up to this issue and you can
give them a hard time for that I do
think that others take it seriously and
they do have a response and again my my
understanding might be imperfect here
but the idea is that they're basically
consequentialists they're saying yes we
are not attributing praise or blame to
individual people what we are instead
doing is saying what can we do to make
the world a better place like what is
the right thing to have happen to
improve the conditions of the world to
make sure generally positive outcomes
happen so you don't need to blame Hitler
but you can still stop them you can
still stop Hitler from doing what he did
uh maybe even killing Hitler maybe even
throwing him in jail or whatever but
certainly the fight against Hitler can
be completely Justified even if you
don't believe in free will even that
even that little bit of slightly better
response has the problem that you know
you're trying to persuade people of this
point of view but you've admit that
people don't make decisions including
yourself you haven't really made the
decision to try to persuade people I'm
not sure if there is any coherent l in
spot for people who don't believe in
Free Will and who still want to get
through the day making choices of their
own trying to persuade other people to
make choices Etc but that's not my job
to make that coherent that's their
job Daniel Bagley says I'm a late person
reading Hawkings A Brief History of Time
in the chapter on the origin of fate of
the universe when he talks about the
inflationary period after the big bang
he says that different regions should
not have been able to achieve the
uniformity we see now because the
information would not have been able to
travel faster than this speed of light
but couldn't entanglement have played a
role such that particles weren't
exchanging information but were
simultaneously affecting each other or
does this represent a fundamental
misunderstanding of
entanglement sorry to say but yes this
represents a fundamental
misunderstanding of entanglement
entanglement does not allow you to push
around one particle based on affecting
the other particle um in particular if I
have two particles that are entangled so
I know that you know let let's say that
there's this spin of two particles is
entangled okay but one particle has a
location far away from the
other I can take the particle that is
far away one of the particles so their
spins are entangled I can move it I can
manipulate it I can you know pick it up
I can put it in a basket I can put in
electric field I can do all sorts of
things to it as long as I don't measure
its spin literally nothing happens to
the other particle there's no Force no
influence no communication between them
the only thing that would eventually be
an effect is if I measure the spin of
that one particle and then I know what
the spin of the other particle is but
guess what that doesn't make them more
smooth or homogeneous it just brings to
life one of the options that were
already there in the wave function of
the combined two particle system so
there's no way that you can actually use
entanglement to smooth things out if
they fundamentally weren't or to
communicate from one part of the
universe to the other what their local
condition should be at some certain
position uh moment in time so it doesn't
help in particular in smoothing the
universe out uh at Early times in the
way that inflation does by good
old-fashioned local
physics Matt Smith says could you please
help me understand why the thermodynamic
Arrow of time is necessary to explain
why we we perceive there to be a past
and future we are part of a universe and
the act of us experiencing something and
it being committed to our memory is
itself a physical process a physical
process that will like all physical
processes be reversible I appreciate
that the thermodynamic errow of time
explains why it is overwhelmingly
unlikely that a physical process is as
complicated as seeing an egg breaking
and creating a memory of that could
happen in Reverse but it seems to me
that a more fundamental point is that
even if the physical process were to
happen in reverse then we wouldn't have
the
memory yeah I think that this whole
story about the arrow of time and
memories and things like that really
doesn't make any sense unless you accept
a distinction between the microscopic
level and the macroscopic level at the
microscopic level all of these processes
are reversible like you say but at the
macroscopic level they are not they are
not reversible in a thermodynamic sense
in a probabilistic sense but still for
all intents and purposes they are
irreversible um and that has crucial
consequences uh but the the argument is
subtle to be honest you know you can say
as I've said I wrote a whole book about
it from eternity to here that you're
welcome to read where I go into these in
great detail if you care about them but
the point is that in you you are saying
on the one hand that entropy is
increasing and that gives rise to an
arrow of time but on the other hand the
AR of time has a lot of manifestations
like causality aging memory Etc it is
still work to show why the fact that
entropy is increasing is the reason why
you have memories of the past and not
the future
but you can do it so for example think
of a simple example think of a footprint
in the sand right a footprint in the
sand is in some sense a memory you see
it and you go aha I bet there was a foot
there at some point in other words the
way it works is there's some feature of
the current macroscopic world the
footprint from which you can deduce
something about the past the existence
of a foot that stepped there you can't
deduce everything you don't know when
the foot went there but you can say
something things about it it wasn't you
know 5 years ago or it would have washed
away by now if it's a fossil that's a
different question and you don't have
that same access to the Future you can't
say from the existence of the footprint
now what it will be like uh a day from
now maybe we'll wash away maybe an
asteroid will hit the earth and destroy
everything you just don't know maybe
another foot will step there and put
another footprint there so where does
that asymmetry come from and the answer
is from entropy increasing
because when you take the footprint in
the current moment of the universe and
ask what you can infer from that about
both the past and the future when you're
inferring about the past you have an
extra piece of information an extra
handle that tells you something and
implicitly or explicitly that extra
handle is the fact that the early
Universe had low entropy from that fact
from the combination of number one the
early Universe had low entropy and
number two there is a footprint here in
the sand today you can infer number
three that there was a foot that put the
footprint there and the way that you do
it and again no one does this explicitly
but this is the underlying idea is you
consider all of the different ways in
which the fundamental laws of physics
could have ended up with a footprint
there and you ask what is most probable
given the boundary conditions of the low
enty past and the footprint and it turns
out that with those boundary conditions
the most probable intermediate
trajectories involve feet stepping on
the sand you can't do the same thing
with the future because there is no
future boundary condition of low entropy
the universe as far as we know just
wanders off into some state in the far
future and that gives you much less of
an epistemological handle on what can
happen in the future so it is ultimately
all because entropy is increasing if you
were lus demon and you knew what every
little micro atom in the universe was
doing exactly then you would have
perfect knowledge of both the past and
the future and you wouldn't talk about
memory or causality or entropy or any of
those things but you are not lassus
demon as I often remind
people Philip malanowski says in
conversation with David Deutsch he was
talking about an Ever ready
interpretation of quantum mechanics in
the Heisenberg picture when observables
are evolving instead of the wave
function at the level of basic quantum
mechanics the schinger Heisenberg
pictures are equivalent but they seem to
suggest different interpretations of
mechanics in your favorite case of many
worlds interpretation is there a
difference between schinger Everett and
Heisenberg Everett it feels for example
the bomy interpretation would be hard to
reconcile with the Heisenberg picture
you know I haven't thought about this
very deeply but my belief is that it is
not just at a level of basic that
scheringer and Heisenberg pictures are
equivalent I think they are exactly
equivalent I think that there's no sense
in which it the theory Works in one pict
picture and doesn't work in the other it
is very frequently and commonly the case
in theoretical physics that you can have
two equivalent pictures and one is more
helpful than the other and the word
helpful can be interpreted in various
ways it can be helpful in the sense of
solving the equations or it can be
helpful in the sense of suggesting ways
to expand the equations and go beyond
the picture you currently have so there
are often very good reasons to work in
one picture rather than the other but at
a philosophical level at a deep
ontological level where you're asking
about what the world is I truly think
there is no
difference J Jason richardi says I liked
your ex poost uh formerly Twitter that
states responses to this have been kind
of depressing I have my own degree of
skepticism but there's been way too much
superficial dismissal ambitious new
theories will often seem weird knee-jerk
reactions make it harder to investigate
truly novel ideas this is this is Sean
talking now um uh something that I put
in response to the assembly Theory paper
that appeared in nature this is a paper
by uh a collaboration of people Lee
Cronin and Sarah Walker Sarah Walker is
a former mindscape guest were the most
uh the people most close closely
associated with this assembly Theory
idea but also Christopher Kemp and
Michael lochman are two other friends of
mine from the Santa Fe Institute who
worked on it and also abash Sharma and
Danielle seel worked on it so they all
you know have some involvement here
don't it's always a mistake to uh sort
of collapse a paper to its most famous
authors by the way anyway um let me
finish Jason's question can you explain
how Dr cronin's assembly Theory see I
don't like that you know it's it's a
shared assembly Theory and their teex
stack at chifi which I have no knowledge
of challenges the status quo what are
the novel ideas versus already
established ideas and why has it caused
friction in the community so for those
of you who don't know assembly theory is
um a set of ideas about how complex
structures are assembled thus the title
in the real world and I have you know
like I say in in the tweet I have um my
own degree of skepticism but I also
think that there's a lot to it and I
don't understand it very deeply I've not
written any papers about it or anything
like that but what they're pointing out
is that the space of all possible
complicated things you can make is very
very big okay and this is something I
mean it's a trivial statement but it's
also a very very important statement and
one that I myself have been thinking
about quite a lot the space of things
you can make is very big and therefore
it's important to consider the ways in
which things get made because we don't
make by we I mean the universe doesn't
make every complicated thing and try it
out okay there is a history that helps
explain why certain things are made and
certain things are not so assembly
Theory tries to take advantage of this
fact by pointing out that if you see
certain kinds of configurations of
complicated things on some other planet
then the most likely way to make those
complicated things under certain
conditions which they try to um explain
is because there is life there is some
element of design even if it's just the
illusion of design that you often get
from natural selection it's not just
random selections of different chemicals
coming together there's some process
that is making them and that could be
very helpful when you're looking for
life on other planets it can also just
be helpful trying to explain the um
Evolution I guess of life here on Earth
uh what I don't like is some Advocates
of assembly Theory and and here Sarah
Walker and and Lee Cronin I think are
guilty are way more willing than I would
ever be to say that somehow this view
suggests that we should modif ify the
underlying laws of physics no longtime
listener of mindscape will be surprised
to hear that I am very skeptical about
the idea we should go from something
complicated like the origin and
evolution of life to something basic
like let's change the laws of physics I
think that's utterly wrong there's no
justification for that it's kind of
silly and the paper that appeared in
nature uh a little while ago kind of you
know doesn't push that aspect of the
theory very strongly but does elude to
it and it has some provocative sentences
in there so what I was disappointed
about that I indicated in the Tweet is
sure you can be skeptical of some of the
more outrageous aspects of this
structure you can be absolutely critical
of some of the ways the theory was
presented in this paper and How It Was
Written but it there's still good ideas
in the theory and rather than talking
about personalities or writing styles or
whatever talk about the ideas you know
um I I don't care whether it's
challenging the status quo and whether
it's young upstarts versus established
ideas who cares who cares about any of
that I care about whether it's
right and most of the time when you have
a new idea it might be at best partly
right and partly wrong so okay so you do
the work you you say like what aspects
of this are useful and which are not the
thing that I didn't like about the uh
need reaction on on Twitter and
elsewhere was you know an
idea basically there is a feature of
interesting new ideas that they are too
easy to dismiss and look I know as well
as anyone that this kind of statement is
one that crackpots love to make because
crackpots will always say you're just
just dismissing my ideas without paying
close attention to them right so there's
a judgment call that comes in uh I I am
totally in favor of dismissing crackpot
ideas I'm totally in also in favor of
taking seriously ideas that are not
crackpot but are a little bit out of the
mainstream and there's a judgment call
that comes in in distinguishing between
those two cases to me assembly theory is
clearly on the side of not completely
crackpot there's parts of it that I
disagree with but there's some
interesting stuff there so if you
disagree with it that's fine um people
who I know and admire on Twitter uh
including some former mindscape guests
who I won't name appeared on both sides
of this argument some were saying like
ah this is just nonsense others were
saying no actually here's why here's the
kernel of an interesting idea there
that's fine I mean the the disagreement
is fine it might all turn out to be
useless and wrong for all I know but
there was just too much dismissal on the
basis of style and not enough dismissal
on the basis of or not enough engagement
on the basis of the substance
and I think that's too easy to do with
new interesting ideas to engage with
their style rather than with their
substance and by doing that we make it
hard to propose new ideas let's put it
this way something that anyone who has
ever tried to write an interesting
science paper knows is that it is way
easier to get an uninteresting science
paper past the referees than it is an
interesting science paper because you
know interesting and uninteresting are
orthogonal to correct and incorrect
right you can be interesting but
incorrect interesting incorrect
uninteresting also likewise if you are
uninteresting and correct that is the
easiest way to get your paper published
because some Journal is absolutely going
to publish your paper if it's
uninteresting and correct if it's
interesting and possibly correct but not
obviously it is much harder to get your
paper published because there could be
some referee that just looks at and goes
Eh this is not the way I usually think
about these things
reject clearly I mean obviously I can I
can give you many examples in my own
career where the boring papers I've
written sail through the refereeing
process and the interesting ones
sometimes have trouble sometimes they're
accepted because people get it but
sometimes they run into trouble because
people just don't want to engage with
something that is new and different and
I think that's what uh that's part of
what the assembly Theory paper is
running up against people just you know
find it too easy to sneer and move on
with their lives rather than think hard
about a new
idea Caster poock said is there a way to
revert a black hole to normal matter
like a neutron star just a regular star
or once you go black you never go back
I'm talking about the theoretical
possibility not a practical
solution it depends on how theoretical
you want to be um a black hole is the
highest entropy configuration that you
can have within a certain sized region
of SpaceTime so if you want to limit
yourself to physical processes that are
compatible with the second law of
Thermodynamics you have to make higher
entropy configuration than the black
hole and you can't make a higher entropy
configuration in a limited region of
space you can if you give yourself more
space so the reason why black holes can
evaporate is because they evaporation
products the photons Etc that come out
spread themselves over a much larger
region of space and have a higher
entropy than the original black hole did
if you want to take that black hole
without spreading it out all over space
and turning it into a neutron star or a
regular star or whatever you will be
decreasing its entropy therefore it's
not going to happen in the real world
but of course as boltzman taught us it
could happen it's possible it's just
super duper duper unlikely so don't
actually try to do do it it's you know
when I say it's hard to impress upon
people how super duper unlikely it is
it's not anything that you should even
waste a moment of your time thinking
about let's put it that way Georgio says
I was wondering how you on a personal
level deal with the discrepancy of
personal well-being and the suffering of
so many people around the world how can
I ever be happy knowing there are humans
around the world who never in their
lives have felt secure or protected and
live in constant fear of pain or Worse
especially of course in regards to
recent events around the world I often
find myself incapable of enjoying my own
life that is so very different do you
struggle with similar feelings and if so
how do you deal with that I think it's
very valid to struggle with these
feelings uh but I think you know I I
think I'm pretty consistent here I'm
going to advocate for a diverse
ecosystem that diverse ecosystem applies
to your personal feelings and activities
as well as it does to other aspect ects
of life so I think it's important to
care about the suffering of others
elsewhere in the world I also think it's
important not to be overwhelmed by the
suffering of others elsewhere in the
world you're not doing them any good by
just being overwhelmed by their
suffering if you want to quit your job
and and move around the world and try to
help other people that's great that's a
thing to do I don't think there's any
moral obligation to do that I do think
that you should try to make the world a
little bit better but I don't think that
the way to act in life is to look around
the world decide what is the worst thing
going on and devote yourself to fixing
that thing that is absolutely an okay
thing to do in fact it's a very um
admirable thing to do don't get me wrong
I just don't think there's any
obligation to do it I think that
different people will have different
roles to play in the world and there are
different puzzles to be solved different
problems to be solved if I didn't think
that I certainly wouldn't be a
theoretical physicist or philosopher
right I think that I think the problems
that I devote myself to are important
but they're probably not the most
pressing problems in the world right now
they are some intersection of important
problems problems that I am personally
able to make some progress on and
problems that I enjoy trying to make
progress on so there's some combination
to that I also allocate some fraction of
my time and attention and
uh monetary donations to other problems
that I think are worth pressing on so I
will talk about other things this is as
you might have have noticed this podcast
is not purely about physics Andor
philosophy it's about lots of different
things because I think many things are
important at once so I think that it's
perfectly okay to care about these
things to feel bad um that the whole
world is not happy that's something that
is absolutely valid to care about but
the solution is not to let that paralyze
you and the solution is not to feel
guilt about it the solution is to sort
of live a life that makes you happy
while also working to make other people
happy in whatever little way that you
can let's put it this way if everyone
did that the world would be an
enormously better
place Kevin contras says I have a
philosophical question involving maths
thinking about how mathematical models
can make sense internally but don't
correspond with our experience of the
world or just can't be proven it makes
me wonder why does this happen it's
maybe like math is like any other
language in the sense that it can't
really grasp Concepts outside of our
experience like they're just an
extension of our own capacity and by
default prone to our own errors or are
they really or do they really or some
there's a misprint in in this sentence
sorry do they really are they really
something separate that we are just not
interpreting correctly you know I do
struggle with this idea of the
objectivity of man without getting into
questions of the realism of math right I
think that this was an important
distinction I learned from Justin Clark
Don you can have in principle you could
imagine that math is objective without
being a mathematical realist okay I do
think that math is objective I do think
that if you have a set of axioms and you
prove theorems from it that is an
objective fact in the sense that every
single person who understands those
axioms and the rules of math would prove
the same theorems or would at least
agree that you have proven those
theorems and I don't think that those
theorems necessarily need need to have
any connection with the real world um
you know the world might be finite but
mathematically we can still talk about
Infinity let's give that as a particular
example but there might be many other
examples I do think it's at least
possible to me I would like to suggest
the possibility even though I can't
Advocate it fully because I'm not an
expert here that there are various
puzzles and paradoxes in mathematics and
mathematical logic that arise from the
fact that precisely the fact that we
take math and push it beyond what
happens in the physical world and maybe
we shouldn't be bothered by these
puzzles and paradoxes if they only arise
in the parts of math that don't
correspond to anything in the physical
world I don't know if that's a valid
perspective or not but I would at least
like to pull it up the flag pole see if
anyone
salutes Chris V says it can be argue
that it is morally possible to become a
billionaire however do you think it is
morally defensible to remain one over
time a billion being simply an arbitrary
threshold uh sure yeah I I have no
problem with that in fact Let me let me
um extend let me let me use your
question Chris to uh to rant about this
a little bit I think that in the modern
world there is too much inequality I
think you know there are too many super
rich people and far too many poor people
I think that's true but I also think
that people who object to this state of
affairs are far too prone to making it
somehow about individual virtue I think
that's just a huge mistake I think that
putting the onus on wealthy people to
feel guilty and give away all of their
money is in some sense in some very real
sense making the problem worse or at
least providing cover for the problem to
continue to exist this is a societal
level problem this is not an individual
level problem if a certain individual
spends their time complaining about
billionaires being too rich Etc maybe
that makes them feel better and and
makes them morally Superior to think
that they you know would give away all
their money that they don't actually
have and they feel good because they're
giving away other people's money in
their imaginary thought experiments it's
not making the world a better place the
way to make the world a better place is
to change the system sorry that's a
little bit less romantic a little bit
harder to do people try to do it all the
time it rarely works I get it it's still
the right way to do it and by changing
the system I don't mean Revolution and
overthrowing everything I just mean
having taxes that people pay I've said
this before and I still think it's true
billionaires are not the problem the
problem is taxes should be higher on
billionaires and they should pay them
and then we can use that money to do
good things in the world this is a
resolutely unromantic point of view I
get it and furthermore I absolutely feel
the objection that people try this and
it doesn't work okay but guess what
people also try guilting billionaires
into giving away their money and that
doesn't work either so I don't think
that's a great argument I think that the
best possible hope for more Equitable
Society is to work at the level of
changing Society not working at the
level of making individuals Feel
Bad Walter Miller says is there a
magnetic field that permeates the entire
universe ierse and if so what generates
that field well I wouldn't say there is
a magnetic field that permeates the
Universe there are there is at every
point a value of the magnetic field
there's one magnetic field that takes on
different values in different places
some places it could be zero some places
it might not be I think the scientific
version of this question is are there
magnetic fields let's say in between the
galaxies okay in galaxies there are
processes like Supernova and star
formation and just good old Stellar
process processes that generate some
magnetic fields and there are dynamos
and batteries that people in
astrophysics talk about and study in
great detail neutron stars for example
have extremely strong magnetic fields
what we want to know is are there
primordial magnetic fields were they
there in the early universe and do they
are there still remnants of them in
between the galaxies or there are no
stars to generate them
Etc we don't know there's some evidence
there is some tentative astrophysic
physical evidence that this is true that
there are some magnetic fields out there
they're not too big so they're not like
crazily inexplicable or anything but
there's some motivation for thinking
about how to generate primordial
magnetic fields that could help us
explain the existence of magnetic fields
in between galaxies I know about this
because I just wrote a paper about it um
you know this is generally not what I do
these days but my advisor from grad
school George field and I just did
collaborate on um a a way to possibly
make magnetic fields by the way using
axons using the same axons that could be
the Dark
Matter this this is an old idea that if
you have axion-like Fields you can
generate magnetic fields through the
evolution of the Axion it is generally
thought that that would have to happen
in the super early Universe before
inflation or something like that or
during inflation because otherwise you
have a Charged plasma it's very highly
electrically conducting and it's hard to
make field when you have a in the middle
of a conductor okay they're just shorted
out by the Motions of the particles what
we point out is that in the presence of
this Axion field there's kind of a new
degree of Freedom there's a mode of the
magnetic field or the electric field
really that is shorted out by the
Motions of charged particles but there's
also one that isn't there's a new
there's a new degree of freedom because
of the Axion so you can have some fields
that are not shorted out and they can
actually grow and we talk about how much
they could grow by I don't know if
that's the right Theory but you know if
you if we find that axons are the dark
matter I think it' be very interesting
to check whether or not they're also
responsible for Intergalactic magnetic
fields Joe adder or ader ader says do
you believe the lone genius idea drives
scientific progress more than
collaborative science do you think this
has shifted over time do you think
Awards like the Nobel Prize are helping
or hurting with respect to this you know
I do believe there are lone genius es I
don't think that they play a huge role
in the progress of science here's one
little piece of evidence for that um
comes from Jeffrey West our former
mindscape guest and former president of
the Santa Fe Institute if you look at
the number of good ideas that are
generated by people uh you can figure
out how you're going to measure that you
know by patents or Nobel prizes or
whatever guess what in cities or in
dense concentrations of people not only
are there more patents and Nobel prizes
because there are more people there are
more patents and Nobel prizes per
person that come out of Highly collected
highly concentrated sets of people than
you would expect uh then there are in
dilute sets of people right and in
retrospect this makes no surprise at all
because people talk to each other even
the Geniuses even the Einstein the
Newtons whatever they absolutely build
build on the ideas of other people um
you know there were a lot of people of
Einstein or Isaac Newton level IQs back
there who lived 10,000 years ago none of
them invented Newtonian mechanics why
well because it takes a lot of builtup
it might be imperceptible it might be
cumulative in very very background kind
of ways but you know newon knew about
Kepler's laws he knew about Galileo's
experiments that stuff matters and so
even if it's not immediately visible I
think that scient science advances
through collaboration and communication
as far as the Nobel Prize I don't know I
I like the Nobel prizes because they
bring attention and publicity to good
science that might not otherwise get it
they certainly also distort science in
various ways I have no way of judging
whether the positive aspects are bigger
or smaller than the negative
ones Adam small says if a bubble chamber
was placed between the slits in the
screen and double slit experiment and
the same particles that produce tracks
in a bubble chamber are passed through
the slits would you see interference or
would you see the tracks as they emerge
from the slits uh if I understand your
setup you would just see tracks going
from the slits because a bubble chamber
that can detect particles is certainly
measuring the particles it once the
particles are being measured in between
the slits and the detection screen on
the other side you have measured them
they are now particle like they have
tracks they're not going to interfere
with each other they're no longer
waves yosis asks a priority question can
the CMB The Remnant energy from the
early Universe be the reason for dark
matter and if not why I don't know what
you mean by the reason for dark matter
but um putting that confusion aside the
answer is no it cannot be for the for
the reason that the CMB is not matter it
is
radiation when astronomers or
cosmologists use the word matter they
don't just mean stuff they
for very particular reasons mean stuff
that is moving slowly compared to the
speed of light okay in cosmology speak
matter is particles that are moving
slowly compared to the speed of light
radiation is particles that are moving
at or near the speed of light so very
very low mass neutrinos can still be
radiation even though they're particles
and uh photons are just not matter
because they are always moving at the
speed of light the reason for that
distinction is the amount of energy
density in matter versus radiation thus
construed changes in a different way as
the universe expands if you're moving
slowly compared to the speed of light
then your energy comes mostly from eal
MC squared from the mass of U as a
particle and if you have a bunch of
particles who each get their energy from
their masses then the energy density
just goes as the number density of
particles which ex which goes down as
the volume of the the Universe goes up
whereas if you are moving at or close to
the speed of light your energy does not
come from E equals mc^2 your energy
comes from your kinetic energy or if
you're moving at the speed of light just
from your frequency okay as as a wave
and therefore you red shift you lose
energy as the universe expands and as a
result the total energy density goes
down both because the number density
particles goes down as the universe
expands and because every particle is
losing energy so to a cosmologist matter
is particles that don't individually
lose energy as the universe expands uh
radiation is particles that do move that
do lose energy as the universe expands
one thing we know about dark matter is
that it's matter in fact not only is it
slowly moving compared to the speed of
light now it was slowly moving compared
to the speed of light in the early
Universe if it hadn't been it would not
have settled into galaxies and clusters
and made the large scale structure we
observe today so the microwave
background radiation cannot be the Dark
Matter Ryan Santos says as an educator
do you find that Variety in coursework
and school activities improve student
performance if so do you have any
theories as to why this
is I don't have a lot of data about this
and I am a believer in data so you
should not really believe my anecdotal
Impressions compared to someone who's
actually studying it but my anecdotal
impression is that probably yes um you
know most learning happens in the minds
of the students not in the words of the
professors or the teachers or the
reading or whatever if the student is
not going to engage with the material
then they're not going to learn as much
and I think the variety is important for
two reasons number one different
students become engaged for different
reasons so you never know what is going
to engage a particular student and
number two even one particular student
might get bored of the same kind of
thing over and over again right whether
it's a lecture every day or problem sets
every day or whatever variety is the
spice of life so it's variety because
you want to keep the students engaged
that I think sounds useful to me uh but
I don't have a lot of data one way or
the
other OA owwe says I'm trying to spin up
on postmodern philosophy and was reading
through the Wikipedia page as a starter
it states quote many postmodernists
appear to deny that an objective reality
exists and appear to deny that there are
objective moral values the latter seems
reasonable to me but the latter
seems I think maybe there's a mistake
here one of them he says the latter in
both cases but I think that probably
what o is trying to say is the latter
seems reasonable but the former seems
pretty hard to take at face value what
is the basis for rejecting an objective
reality is it anything other than a red
Abed serum to take that the existence of
reality can't truly be proven how is
this useful in practice so there's a lot
to say here number one Wikipedia as much
as I love it which is very much uh
probably isn't the best place to get an
education on postmodern philosophy
especially a sentence that starts
something like many postmodernists
appear to deny something right so it's
just full of weasel words what do you
mean many postmodernists how many which
ones and they appear to deny so you're
saying they didn't actually deny I think
that the reason why such a sentence like
that exists in the Wikipedia article is
probably someone had a belief that
postmodernists do deny the existence of
objective reality but they couldn't find
a quote where any actual postmodernist
was doing that so they kind of made up a
sentence that said they appear to deny
it um I think you you not it's not
impossible to find such quotes but
they're not as common as you might think
because most postmodernists the good
ones are a little bit more subtle than
that the other thing is that most
postmodernists are not talking about
science they're not talking about
physics or chemistry or biology some of
them are there's a whole you know
science studies subfield that takes a
postmodern tack on what science does uh
but when when people are willing to say
you know re um the reality around you is
socially constructed they usually are
thinking about in the back of their
minds social realities social categories
social norms things like that and there
the case that it's socially constructed
is much easier to make even when it does
come to physics or other scientific
things at a strict level of course
things are socially constructed the idea
of a quark is something that someone
invented at some point someone literally
constructed that idea right now it might
map on to something objectively real
about the world but the idea of it is
socially constructive so I think that I
mean you can listen the closest I think
we came here was uh Sally hasslinger was
on the podcast and talked precisely
about the social construction of reality
so you should revisit that podcast I
think you can absolutely believe that
the categories that we use to organize
reality are socially constructed while
the reality itself is real is
objectively real so that's what I would
say and I think I would bet that a large
number of postmodernists would actually
go along with that I don't know I don't
have a poll of postmodernists but um
they they I think that to a science
oriented person they seem to be slippery
in some of their statements and a lot of
that slipperiness can be accounted for
when you keep in mind that they're not
trying to talk about or two science
they're trying to talk about the social
World Peter gal says please please
explain how inflationary Theory implies
other universes if indeed it
does well depends on your definition of
Universe okay so cosmologists have
adopted a definition of the word
universe that they use in the context of
the cosmological Multiverse and you
might agree or disagree with the
definition I don't really care whether
you agree or disagree I'm just trying to
explain what it means okay what it means
is a large region of space where the
local laws of physics so you know the
masses of the particles how they
interact with each other and so forth
are all more or less uniform through the
region okay so our observable universe
is one such Universe you look out at the
distant galaxies and the microwave
background they clearly seem to be
compatible with the same laws of physics
that we have here but in the
cosmological Multiverse idea there could
be regions very very far away that are
themselves very large and the local laws
of physics look different so we call
those different
universes then if you accept that
definition
inflation often I don't want to say
always because I don't think that's true
and I don't even know how often it is
but let's just say often models of
inflation lead to this kind of
cosmological Multiverse or at least
let's be even more careful than that
open the possibility of this kind of
cosmological Multiverse different models
of inflation allow so let's let's back
up one thing that inflation is supposed
to do is to explain or to provide an
account of the fluctuations in
temperature and density that we see in
our universe including the cosmic
microwave background and those
fluctuations are small one part in 10
the five but it is easy in fact it
naturally pops out that if inflation
happened there is some regime in which
when inflation was happening the
fluctuations were large much bigger than
10us 5 so large that even though the INF
flaton field that is causing inflation
and is gradually diminishing in energy
sometimes fluctuates upward in energy
and makes a new universe keeps going and
this is what we call Eternal inflation
because somewhere in space inflation is
going to keep going and that's going to
make more and more universes and that is
half the battle if you want to make a
cosmological Multiverse the other half
of the battle is can you in different
post-inflationary regions have different
local laws of physics there are many
versions of fundamental physics in which
you can string theory is one such
version there's other versions also but
we don't know if any of those theories
of fundamental physics is right so
inflation can bring to life different
local laws of physics if the fundamental
laws of physics allow for such a thing
but we don't know if it happens so
inflation can imply other universes but
it doesn't necessarily have
to Cubit says whilst trying to
understand the concept of effective
field theories I wondered about the
following point you have mentioned that
the Infinities of quantum field
theoretic calculations disappear when
formulated on a discrete lattice having
some experience in numerical simulations
that doesn't seem to make any sense to
me is it really the case that I'm not
allowed to choose an arbitrarily fine
grid within my simulation because
otherwise my results become worse at
some unknown Point well I think this is
I don't know what kind of numerical
simulations you have uh experience with
there is a difference between classical
field Theory or fluid mechanics Etc and
Quantum field theory in this case and
one of the differences is this in a
classical field Theory you expect that
the real Fields you're looking at become
smoother and smoother as you look at
them in smaller and smaller length
scales there is usually some typical
scale of oscillation or maybe there is
some smallest scale scale at which
oscillations are really important
because very very small scale
oscillations can cost a lot of energy so
they're just not there in a classical
field you would expect if you zoomed in
on a region of space and looked at
smaller and smaller regions you would
eventually start seeing less and less
motion less and less Divergence from
place to place in Quantum field Theory
it's not like that because in Quantum
field Theory you have virtual particles
as well as real ones and for real
particles they would all have some
wavelength that's longer than a certain
amount Etc but the whole point of
quantum field theory is that there are
contributions to scattering experiments
Etc from wave modes with shorter and
shorter and shorter wavelengths every
wavelength keeps contributing you keep
getting new contributions as you go to
smaller and smaller wavelengths indeed
that is where the Infinities come from
so you can very easily imagine a
situation where the classical numerical
simulation has no Infinities in it you
just need to pick a Lattis spacing that
is small enough that things react
relatively smoothly whereas a Quantum
version of that Things become infinite
when you get smaller and smaller grid
sizes and what Wilson realized is that
in some real sense that smaller that
those Infinities that only begin to show
up as you look at smaller and smaller
grid sizes are not really physical
they're not really there we know that
the final answer is a finite number
so the Infinities that showed up in your
calculation are artifacts of your
calculation they're not real and so he
invented effective field Theory to show
you how to get finite answers without
ever having Infinities at some
intermediate point along the
way Colleen Edwards says with
psychedelic drugs like MDMA musculin Etc
being studied more as potential
therapies for treating post-traumatic
stress disorder depression and anxiety
disorders Etc I'm curious what your take
is on this if you're for it or against
it and why have you ever experimented
and if so were you lucky enough to have
had a profound experience on your trip
so yeah I'm for it I mean I I kind of
want to skirt around the question
because why am I supposed to know
anything or why are you or why is anyone
supposed to know anything about the
relative merits of different possible
therapies for these kinds of
disorders there's probably lots of
different things that may or may not be
useful for these kinds of disorders I
think that individuals feel that they
have some insight into psychedelic one
way or the other psychedelics um some
people have very positive feelings about
them some people have very negative
feelings about them in ways that they
might not have very strong feelings
about non psychedelic um chemicals and
drugs and things like that so I feel
about them the same way I feel about any
other possible the therapy or possible
um treatment for these disorders try
them out see if they work I have no
strong emotional attachment one way or
the other I had if you're interested
Robin carart Harris on the podcast where
we talked about exactly this he is
someone who does Research into
psychedelics and I think that from
talking to him and from talking to other
people Etc it seems that these uh
psychedelic therapies are potentially
extremely useful there's even kind of a
you know cheap and easy hand wavy
explanation for why they are useful
namely that you know the brain is a
complicated thing it works in a very
complicated way but one thing is that
you know it tries different things it
doesn't it tries not to fall into a rut
and all of
these um examples of disorders
depression anxiety disorders PTSD in
some way in different ways all of these
are examples of falling into ruts in
thinking the same thing over and over
again and not being able to escape and
in again some very handwavy way a Common
Thread of different psychedelics is that
they help the brain escape from its ruts
um they let the brain explore a little
bit more that's why it kind of seems you
know psychedelic and a little
hallucinatory you're exploring things
that you don't usually explore actually
those things again in at a handwavy
level are already there in your brain
and what the psychedelics are doing are
lowering your inhibitions to noticing
them they're not creating them in the
first place so you know if that story
holds together then I'm completely um
willing to think that these are going to
play a huge role therapeutically but one
way or the other I want people to do the
tests and find out whether they actually
work as I have mentioned previously uh
on the podcast and elsewhere uh I did
LSD once that was my only psychedelic
experience and I would say it was fun
but it was not profound I don't know
what I don't I I'm very skeptical
of the profoundness of such experiences
I mean we do know a little bit about
what's going on when you do psychedelics
you're lowering the inhibitions that
your brain usually throws up to
listening into the noise that is going
on in the background of your brain at
all times that can be fun I don't see
how it would be profound I certainly
don't see any way that it's giving you
any special insight into the fundamental
nature of reality or anything like
that Kyle Stevens says Isaac asal's
Foundation series describes a future
where knowledge becomes fragmented and
specialized to the point where
scientists become increasingly focused
on narrow topics and the broader
understanding of science is lost do you
think this fragmentation is happening
today is any of your motivation to be
cross-disciplinary to keep this from
happening you know I don't think I can
keep this from happening all by myself I
do think it's happening uh I have mixed
feelings about it look I think you have
to be honest about the fact that science
is still progressing at an amazing rate
where doing wonderful things in science
there are absolutely good reasons why
scientists hypers specialize there's too
much knowledge out there you can't be an
expert in everything if you had to pick
one single way to be a scientist and
make every scientist be that way the
best way would be to hypers specialize
in different areas so that we could move
forward in all these different areas now
we don't need to make a rule where every
scientist has to be the same kind of
sciencetist we could imagine that there
are some scientists whose job it is to
hypers specialize and push particular
areas forward and others whose job it is
to be more generalists and understand
multiple areas and try to draw
connections between them I would vastly
prefer if Academia were set up to
encourage both modes of being a
scientist maybe most scientists are
hypers speci Specialists but there's
some out there whose literal job it is
to be interdisciplinary and to draw
connections between them that's not how
Academia is set up I think that's a
shame I think one of the reasons why the
Santa Fe Institute is so successful
scientifically is that they actually do
encourage this and they allow for it
it's one of the goals we have at Hopkins
in setting up the natural philosophy
Forum that we want to provide a place
where scientists of different kinds and
philosophers can get together and be
cross-disciplinary in an environment
expent where that is encouraged where
that is actually the point rather than
merely being
tolerated Robert RX and rescue says when
you talk about sher's cat and you
present the two scenarios where the cat
is awake and standing and asleep and
sitting and you mention that decoherence
happens the atoms and the cat are
different in the two positions in in the
two scenarios but what if the awake and
asleep cat are in exactly the same
position maybe both of the two versions
are sitting still with their eyes closed
Etc the only difference is their
conscious State one is awake the other
is asleep what then well you know it's
it's not a handwavy thing okay it's do
you become entangled with your
environment that is the question the
reason why it's nice to talk about the
case where you're distinguishing between
a cat that is awake and walking around
versus a cat that is asleep and lying on
the ground is because there it's obvious
that you do become entangled with the
environment because photons hit you in
different ways when that's not so
obvious then you got to do more work you
have to think about what is exactly the
difference I mean clearly there's some
difference between the awake cat and the
asleep cat maybe their eyes are
twitching at different rates certainly
what's going on in their brains is
happening at different rates which might
emit different kinds of infrared light
or something like that I don't know the
details that becomes a complicated
biology question but uh I strongly
suspect that they would decohere quite
quickly but You' have to actually do the
calculation um one way or the other once
one of them woke up then they would be
very very different Eric fast says I
know that I should have a Credence of
one in
1024 that a Fair coin will land heads 10
times in a row I might have exactly the
same Credence that we will prove the
twin Prime conjecture in The Next
Century but these intuitively feel like
very different types of credences in the
second example I'm uncertain whether I
should have something closer to 1 in 10
or 1 in 10 million is it enough to
represent a Credence as a number or
should we use something like a set of
probability distributions that capture
our higher order uncertainties I
probably should have grouped this
question sorry to Eric that's buried
down here late in the AMA but I should
have grouped this back up there talking
about the Barry lower question and
self-locating uncertainty in many worlds
here is my take on it but I'll I'll tell
you that my take is not fully developed
and
maybe there's two possibilities one is
that there is a take out there that is
fully developed and I would sign on on
to or number two I need to write a paper
about this where I actually fully
develop my take but my take is that the
kinds of credences they are are the same
in both cases one is a Credence about
the future of our universe right where
and we don't know you know the future of
our universe in terms of coins being
flipped maybe we live in a universe
where you're going to flip the coin and
get heads every time but we don't know
okay we nevertheless have a seemingly
rational objective procedure for
assigning that Credence so the
differences between that and the twin
Prime conjecture is not that it's a
different kind of credence but that we
have a different way of assigning it you
know what I mean we have a handle out
there objectively in the world that
suggests to us that we could that we
should if we have some objectives assign
credences in a certain way whereas in
the Twin Prime conjecture case we don't
don't have those uh we don't have
anything to give us that objective way
of of developing the Credence so I I
would shift the difference there is a
difference in the two cases but the
difference is not in what kind of
credence it is but how we develop it and
I think that's okay that's that that
would be the part that I have to develop
more I don't see any reason why that is
a reason to feel uncomfortable about the
assignments of these credences or of
treating them as the same kind of
underlying
uncertainty Carlos Nunes says Robert
spolski just published a book showing
that showing that we don't have free
will okay I don't think he did that but
he did publish a book given your
compatible stance what evidence would
persuade you to reject the notion of
free will sure I mean sort of as we
discussed earlier uh a better Theory a
theory that fully accounted at least as
well as ordinary psychology does for the
behavior of human beings that doesn't
have the fact that human beings make
choices as part of the theory all you
have to do is in vent that theory show
that it matches the data I will sign on
I will give up on Free Will Blake SE
says is irreversibility just a function
of our ignorance or fundamental Allah
prajin well uh we don't know the
fundamental laws of physics right so
that's always the caveat here so if it's
very possible that the truly fundamental
laws of physics Allah Steven Wolfram for
example are just irreversible I don't
think that's the most likely thing it's
certainly not what we have right now in
many world's quantum mechanics the
fundamental laws are reversible and then
it just becomes a function of our
ignorance to me Prine like Sarah Walker
and Lee Cronin in the assembly Theory
thing or like Philip Goff in the pan
psychism thing are leaping too quickly
from there's something about this
macroscopic phenomenon that's a little
bit mysterious to Let's monkey with the
fundamental laws of physics you don't
have to do that there's enough room in
our ignorance to say someday we'll
figure it out I see no obstacle
whatsoever in completely accounting for
all of the irreversibility that we see
here in the world in terms of the good
old laws of physics as we already know
them boltzman explained it to us and he
he kind of got it right um but of course
we'll have to see maybe our notion of
the fundamental laws of physics isn't in
its final form yet Zachary danzinger
says how useful do you think cellular
automata are as a metaphor for physical
processes or computation EG Conway's
Game of Life or is the actual substrate
for theory of physical law EG wolfram's
ruad well I think they're very useful as
a metaphor I think they're very useful
as ways to learn things about certain
nice physical systems you know I think
the nice thing about cellular aoma is
they're easy to simulate they're easy to
put on a computer and see what happens
so you can study emergence in them for
example one of the most famous
philosophical papers on emergence is by
Mark badow called weak emergence where
he really gets into the idea of weak
emergence and he uses Conway's Game of
Life as an Exemplar of exactly this so
it's very educational in that sense as
an actual substrate for a theory of
physical law I think it's highly
unpromising I think that we have a
situation right now where we un well the
thing that bothers me the most is
there's two things that bother me the
most about celom as an actual substrate
for physical law number one it takes
locality too seriously um the whole idea
the the hypergraphs in wolfram's recent
physics stuff are not quite as wedded to
the idea of locality as the original
cellular aoma theories were but still
it's takes a little bit too literally
the idea of objects with locations in
space and I think that quantum gravity
and quantum mechanics more generally
warn us against that and not everyone is
listening to the warning that's one
thing the other thing is it doesn't take
the idea of reversibility seriously
enough I think that the fundamental laws
of physics since the time of Newton have
been reversible we understand why the
universe looks irreversible to us on the
basis of thermodynamics in emergence and
the second law and the past hypothesis
the idea that you're going to change the
fundamental laws to go back to being
irreversible like they were in
Aristotle's time does not seem to me to
be a step forward I think you're
cheating not not cheating but I think
that you're making your life easy at a
calculational level while ignoring some
of the realities of physics as we truly
understand it I could easily be wrong
about that but that's my
feeling Wayne
j2b that's that's quite a name uh asks
Nobel prizes Loom large in the public
imagination is it true for physicists as
well especially when they start out as
grad students or Junior faculty to what
extent was your career affected by a
desire to work on problems or to go
places where you'd have a shot at doing
groundbreaking enough work to give you a
chance at the no Nobel and do you
finally secretly hope that your work in
the foundations of physics will lead to
a Nobel so let's be very clear my work
in the foundations of physics is not
going to lead to the Nobel Prize I know
that for very very high Credence it's
just not the kind of work that even if
it's really good and really successful
leads to the Nobel Prize the Nobel Prize
is not the prize for the most important
science that gets done it's a very
specific kind of prize Ed Whitten is
never going to win the Nobel Prize
Steven Hawking never did they did very
important work but it was too far away
from the experiments of their time to be
able to win the Nobel Prize so and I
think that most people who become
scientists not everyone for sure but
most figured this out very early I
remember very clearly as an
undergraduate I had it figured out that
the Nobel Prize was not the thing to aim
for a lot of the Nobel Prize winners
just get lucky right I mean penus and
Wilson were not looking for the Cosmic
microwave background but they found it
they 100% deserve the Nobel Prize
because they are the people who
discovered it but it wasn't because they
were especially insightful they were
careful scientists but they weren't even
looking for what they found how in the
world do you arrange your career to
maximize the chances of something like
that happening even you know my friends
Saul pritter Adam ree Brian Schmidt who
won the Nobel Prize for the accelerating
universe they weren't looking for the
accelerating universe they were
measuring the D ceration of the universe
they thought they thought it was going
to be a really important result but they
didn't think it' be the Nobel Prize
because they thought they would be a
decelerating universe right so you know
all power to the people who win the
Nobel Prize but I understood very early
on that that was not the way to organize
your work U which is not to say that I
was ever especially good or clever at
organizing my own research career but I
knew better than that Nick Gaul says in
your episode with Tyler Cohen Cowan I
think
uh you said we still need to understand
what the laws of physics are that push
the wave function of the universe
forward even once you've given the many
worlds could you say more about what the
laws of physics are needed to describe
what drives the Dynamics of the wave
function I.E provides the o yeah you
know so I'm not sure Nick exactly what
your level here is at understanding um
but the answer is the shinger equation
okay so in the many worlds version of
quantum mechanics there's only one
equation it's the rer equation and the
Schrodinger equation does exactly this
it tells you how the wave function of
the universe evolves forward in time and
the way it does it is it proposes a
proportionality between the rate of
change of the wave function the time
derivative of the wave function and
something called the hamiltonian
operator acting on the wave function so
you can think of the hamiltonian
operator as asking a question how much
energy is there in different parts of
the wave function and then it says each
one of these parts is going to evolve at
a certain rate depending on how much
energy it has the more energy the faster
it evolves so that hamiltonian in this
picture con conveys no contains all of
the laws of physics the hamiltonian the
the question that is how fast does the
wave function evolve in what ways does
it evolve is entirely answered by
telling me what the hamiltonian is so
the hamiltonian is the laws of physics
and the hamiltonian is a big Matrix
big means if you tell me the
dimensionality of Hilbert space call it
capital N then this Matrix is an N byn
Matrix we can always choose a basis for
the Matrix where it's diagonal and it's
just the N numbers on the diagonal of
that n byn Matrix but it's a lot of
numbers if you have a big Hilbert space
and those numbers tell you all you need
to know so from this perspective the
challenge the interesting part is going
from that Matrix or this list of numbers
on the diagonal to the specificity of
the world world to the fact that we have
three dimensions of space that we have
certain gauge theories and stuff like
that that is the project that is
currently being
investigated red Antonov says do you
have a favorite topic to
teach well
no I do I can say this
um probably the single most
intellectually rewarding topic that I've
ever taught is general relativity it's
not a coincidence that I wrote a
textbook about it I it before I wrote a
textbook so that's not because I wrote
the textbook but general relativity is
as everyone will tell you it's just
beautiful and self-contained now it does
involve math the the challenge in
teaching general relativity is you spend
a certain number of weeks early in the
course just kind of doing math uh if I
guess if you're super good at teaching
you could figure out how to scatter in
physical applications along the way to
keep people interested but some of your
students are going to love the math
they're going to think that that's great
others are going to say why are we doing
this how do you connect this to the real
world and they're going to get impatient
during that part of the course but by
the time that part is over and you give
them Einstein's equation for general
relativity and then you start putting it
to work in cosmology and black holes and
gravitational waves it is both super
rewarding because all of these topics
are manifestly relevant to Modern
physics and to the world but also super
logical and self-contained you know
general relativity has almost no
prerequisites you even teach special
relativity in the first week and that's
fine special relativity doesn't take a
lot of time to teach you need to know
partial differential equations it helps
you if you know some linear algebra but
there's not a lot of that stuff right
general relativity is its own thing
whereas if you teach cosmology that that
I've also taught like every week it's a
different thing this week you need
thermodynamics this week you need uh
particle physics this week you need
statistics of large scale structure and
it all does add up and and but hang
together but it's not this cumulative
sense of progress that you get when
teaching general relativity so if I had
to pick one it would be that on the
other hand you know what I'm doing right
now like in a philosophy course sitting
around the table with 12 people really
thinking hard and discussing ideas
that's also amazingly wonderful for
separate reasons so that's why it's hard
to pick a single favorite
topic Chris Murray says in the Road to
Reality objection Roger Penrose makes to
many worlds is that an entangled State
can be represented equally well as sums
of many different pairs of states and
that there is no mathematical preference
for which pair should count as the
possible observations what do you say to
that even if correct wouldn't this
problem be shared by all
interpretations maybe it'll be shared by
all interpretations maybe not I can't
speak for all interpretations at once
but this is absolutely not a problem for
many worlds as long as like me you take
the attitude that you don't have
separate world worlds until you have
decoherence and when you have
decoherence the question is answered
there is a if you have a system and an
environment the whole thing the whole
shebang system plus environment is
described by a Quantum wave function but
the system by itself is described by a
density Matrix you can sort of Trace
over you can integrate out or ignore the
environment and just talk about the
system and then there is a unique very
clear basis for that density Matrix in
which it's diagonal and that means that
those are the worlds so the question of
what are the worlds what basis should
you represent them in is not ambiguous
at all you only get into trouble if you
think that many worlds is saying that
even before decoherence there are many
worlds then you can't pick out what the
worlds are and it would sound confusing
but that's not what I do that's not what
I think most people do when they talk
about many
worlds physics kitten says can you help
me understand why quantum computers are
so much faster at least for some
applications it can't be the amount of
information being handled a bit has two
possibilities zero and one and a cubit
has just one more possibility spin up
spin down in a superp position of spin
up and down well I think there's there's
two things going on here um like as you
said I'm glad that you said at least for
some applications quantum computers are
not necessarily faster for every
application there are some applications
for which they definitely are faster at
least if you give me the same number of
cubits that the classical computer has
in bits right which is not the real
world you know the big quantum computers
have dozens of q-bits the big classical
computers have many many more bits than
that so and there's also problems this
is not answering your question but there
will be problems in scaling the quantum
computers it's hard to get many many
cubits entangled and working together
without decohering so that's a challenge
for future Quantum Computing but there
are two ways ways in which quantum
computers give you more oomph give you
more handle on what can happen one is
that it's not true that a cubit has just
one more possibility um if a bit has two
possibilities zero or one a cubit has an
infinite number of possibilities it is a
superposition of spin up and spin down
but it's not necessarily an equal
superposition it is Alpha time spin up
plus beta time spin down where Alpha squ
plus beta squ = 1 or if you want you
could write it as Alpha * spin up plus
the < TK of 1 - Alpha squared times spin
down but then Alpha can be any number
between zero and one in fact that's up
to a you know complex phase we can get
rid of so let's ignore that but there
are an infinite number of numbers
between zero and ones you can have just
a little bit of spin up a a good amount
but not a lot a lot you know all of
these are real possibilities that's
enormously more flexible than a class
classical computer and then more
importantly but also true the the Q bits
can be entangled with each other right
classical bits are not entangled and you
have a possibility in a quantum computer
of having unentangled cubits and in fact
a quantum computer can do everything
that a classical computer can do just by
sticking to cubits that are either pure
spin up or pure spin down and cubits
that are unentangled but the cubits can
be in these arbitrary superp positions
so that gives you more flexibility and
they may or may not be entangled with
each other that gives you a whole
another degree of flexibility so in
order to understand the prise way in
which quantum computers actually are
faster it would help to look at a
certain algorithm that is faster and I
encourage you to do that but the fact
that they can be faster should not be
surprising they're just much more
flexible than classical computers
are Amy Ferguson says when it comes to
your thought process do you feel as if
your thoughts Emer emerge out of
nothingness or is a sense that you
actively construct them well it's
complicated when you talk about the
brain it's always complicated right um
they don't emerge out of nothingness
there's certainly something going on in
my brain this is one reason you know
look there's a very big reason why I do
the podcast okay um the reason this the
reason why you know it's nice doing the
podcast I like to I like people
listening to the podcast that is true I
like having an audience I like the
feeling that I can talk to people and
share some information with them but
deep down I'm a selfish person and I
just want to learn things myself and the
this is why the Pod this is why I do not
optimize the podcast for listenership I
could M very easily uh in various ways
increase the listenership of the podcast
one way would be just to make it purely
physics I'm not unaware of the fact that
if you just focus and give value to your
Audience by having a wrong brand
identity such as this is the podcast to
go to for the most recent word on Modern
physics that would be a bigger sell to a
lot of people it would also be less
useful to me I get an enormous benefit
from talking to all these different
people about all these different kinds
of ideas and as we said before about you
know the thought processes of
individuals versus collaborations you
might not know what the benefit is very
often you know I will I will I I will
confess I've done you know over 250
individual interviews with people on the
podcast I don't remember all of them
while I'm doing them I don't even
remember you know the day later what we
talked about in great detail because
while I'm doing them I'm thinking about
the audio levels and the sound quality
and what question I'm going to ask next
and how much time has passed and all
this stuff so I can often you know
listen and be curious and engage but I'm
not 100% paying attention to as if I
were listening in to a podcast right but
nevertheless it makes an impact on my
brain I am thinking about what they what
they say even as I'm worried about audio
levels I'm absolutely listening to every
word the guest says I might not be
consciously remembering it as well as I
could but unconsciously I think it makes
an impact so anyway podcast aside I read
books and I go to talks and I read
things on the internet and things like
that and it all feeds in in ways that is
imposs are impossible for me to
reconstruct into the ultimate thoughts
that I have now also I play a role in
actively constructing them to the extent
you know you're getting into deep Waters
here about the the self and and I and
Free Will and things like that but
there's a part of my brain that shapes
the import the um inputs that it's
getting both from internal and external
sources so I think both happen is is the
answer you can absolutely
get insight by just you know going to
sleep and waking up with better ideas or
by thinking about X and getting a better
idea about why by distracting yourself I
think there's all sorts of techniques
that you can use to give yourself a a
higher probability of getting a good
idea about something um it's hard to
predict exactly when it will happen
Brandon Lewis says suppose I have a
collection of nuts and bolts placed
randomly into little bins if I sort the
collection by size thread pitch head
type ET
has the mass of the collection increased
by the corresponding decrease in entropy
or is this just a complete misunder
understanding of the way entropy works
you know I think it's an intriguing
suggestion but at the end of the day it
is a misunderstanding of the way entropy
works there's no interaction is the
point between the different kinds of
nuts and bolts you have in your little
bins if I have a fluid if I have you
know oil and water in a glass they inter
interact with each other the energy of
the oil and water molecules depends on
their configuration and then there is a
relationship between the energy or the
mass of the fluid and its entropy but
for the nuts and bolts if I take you
know Two Nuts in a bolt and I put them
in different Arrangements they're not
bumping into each other I presume that
you're not at very very high
temperatures where a literal macroscopic
nut or bolt is bouncing around and
bumping into each other they're probably
just sitting there on the table right in
that case there's essentially no
interaction between them the energy is
completely independent of how you
arrange them so no relationship there
sorry okay final question of this AMA
comes from Sid Huff I don't know if we
should give a prize for the final
question I do I do you know I'll confess
right here as a reward to everyone who
set through this long thing you know I
do try to pick a good final question you
know I try to get a question that I
think you know has something interesting
for me to say I don't want to you know
have the last question of the AMA be
like did you read this book and you like
it and I had to say no I didn't read it
that' be a boring final question so Sid
Huff says Stephen Hawking once declared
that philosophy is dead because it has
not kept up with modern developments and
science particularly physics for saying
this others accused haing of scientism
I.E putting an overly high value on
science relative to other non-scientific
disciplines but is this really a bad
thing if say physics is a better way to
understand the world should it in fact
be more highly valued than say
philosophy and other just other such
primarily non-scientific
disciplines yes it is a bad thing to be
that kind of scientistic you know I
think that the word scientism is thrown
around and is more or less useless you
notice that I never use that particular
word it's just like an insult it's not a
substantive word that is telling me
something useful about what is going on
but I do think that the quote from
Hawking philosophy is dead because it's
not kept up with modern developments of
science is utter
horeshit for one thing philosophy has
kept up with modern developments in
science for another thing philosophy is
not dead for a third thing I know for a
fact that Hawking put that in his book
just because people would talk about it
and it would sell more books okay he
knows better than that himself he
doesn't know it now because he's no
longer with us but he did he knew better
than that he was just trying to be
provocative and it worked you fell for
it other people fell for it also um
there is a analogous or related or
adjacent or nearby statement you could
make that does matter uh that that does
have some truth to it I I don't think
that all philosophers pay as much
attention to developments in science as
they should famously I'll give you an
example of a of a truly great
philosopher David Lewis who we've
already mentioned because of his work on
modal realism in possible worlds he
famously has a quote that says he does
not want his metaphysics to be informed
by developments in physics he's right
there saying I don't want this to happen
I get the reason why he would say that
because metaphysics is supposed to be
prior to physics it's supposed to be The
Logical structure of possibilities not
the actuality that physics cares about
but it is clearly ignoring the fact that
when we human beings try to sit back and
come up with metaphysics try to come up
with the logical structure of
possibilities we're terrible at it we
constantly make mistakes if you honest
and humble you will realize that paying
attention to physics can help you
correct those mistakes that you might
have made maybe an ideal perfect
metaphysics made by beings that never
make mistakes would not need input from
science but real world metaphysics does
so I think that's a valid criticism but
that's not what Hawking was getting at
and what Hawking is getting at is not
true to go to specifically Sid's
question um I don't think I mean what do
you I don't know what it means to say
physics is a better way to understand
the world is physics a better way to
understand biology than biology is I
think that physics is a better way to
understand physics is physics a better
way to understand logic or ethics or
Aesthetics than philosophy is no I think
that the only possible way that anyone
could even utter such a thing is to
confuse what philos philosophy tries to
do with what physics tries to do physics
tries to do different things than
philosophy tries to do I mean a classic
mistake that scientists make when they
complain about philosophy is they say
well I've never been affected by
philosophy the philosophy has never
helped me in my science it never seems
to occur to them that that's not the job
of philosophy to help them their job is
to do science and that's fine they will
always be doing doing philosophy you
can't do physics or other science
without doing philosophy you can only do
it badly the happy news is that for the
vast vast majority of ways of doing
physics or of questions you might want
to answer in physics or biology or
anywhere else you can do fine doing
philosophy badly in precisely the same
way that for the last 100 years we've
been able to do quantum mechanics fine
with the Copenhagen interpretation you
can build a large on collider you can
make lasers you can do a wonderful
collection of things even though you're
doing quantum mechanics badly because
sometimes the question you're asks
doesn't doesn't need that much Precision
you don't need quantum mechanics or
general relativity to plot a trajectory
from the earth to the moon and likewise
most physics questions don't need really
subtle
philosophical um
Insight however that fact tends to BL
LED physicists and other scientists to
the fact that some of their questions
kind of do require careful philosophical
insight and they inevitably get it wrong
the foundations of quantum mechanics and
the foundations of statistical mechanics
are obvious examples but other examples
come about in the Notions of probability
and fine-tuning and naturalness and the
Multiverse and testability and
falsifiability all of which physicists
like to talk about and all of which they
talk about very badly because they're
not educated in philosophy so I don't
think there's a competition between
philosophy and physics and other ways of
understanding the world to see who is
the best I think that depending on what
question you're asking you should use
whatever disciplines are appropriate to
that question and with that I bid you
Ado for this month uh this is the
November AMA we will have a December AMA
at the beginning remember that we don't
have a January AMA because it's
Christmas time it's vacation time here
at mindscape World International
headquarters so come up with good
questions for next month and I will talk
to you then
[Music]
bye-bye
la